anh
alo cho các bạn
anh Đợi mình tí ý
à à
Chỉ cần 5 phút mà thoải mái
à Hôm nay thì ạ Mình cũng
à à
Em chưa biết tâm sự gì ngoài có đúng hôm
trước có ghi lại một cái
Ừ nếu mày Thực ra là mình cũng khá lười
kiểu à
Em đừng nghĩ nhiều mình chủ yếu toàn
ngồi chơi thôi hôm nay mình bắt đầu vào
guồng lại để làm việc
Anh
Tuấn tin nhắn tin nhắn à
anh
Alo Alo ạ
à à
ừ ừ
Ờ Ờ
hôm nay mình tâm sự thì ra là mình mình
chỉ định nói về cái vụ của à
à Hôm trước mình có để có 1
A gọi như nào nhỉ Đầu tiên là cái chữ
top nào cũng cày
thế hiển thị ra là những người đã theo
dõi mình ý
ạ sau đó thì anh Mạnh Tuấn Anh gợi ý là
ý là có thể xem được
những người nổi tiếng là theo dõi mình
bởi vì trong đời nó có sắp xếp theo ạ
những kênh mà được nhiều người theo dõi
thì hôm trước mình thấy có một kênh tận
có đúng kênh thôi là hơn 100.000 người
theo dõi cũng theo dõi mình ok thế chậm
Nhưng mà kênh đấy ra kênh kiểu về người
nổi tiếng cái gì đấy
A
và cách giữa hai một phát chị xuống
thành 5.000 người thôi Thực ra thì
nói thế mà phải thất vọng là thế kia
chứng tỏ Mấy kênh dưới đây chứng cho mấy
kênh bình thường không ạ nghĩa là người
người bình thường nghe theo dõi mình Ừ
nó hợp lý hơn là cái kênh kênh kia kia
cho chẳng biết được ai với ai cả
và cái kênh thứ ba ấy mình nghỉ nhất là
kênh thứ ba nó kêu nha cùng vạn nữ tính
cho các bạn khá xinh
Anh hợp âm gì đó
ờ ờ
A và quan trọng là bạn này cũng là một
tí Locker gì vậy ạ
3 cách mạng để có lạ hơn 5.000 người
theo dõi thôi nhưng mà toàn bộ những cái
video bạn đấy điều chỉnh sửa cho chỉnh
chu và nói chung ngoài như có một đội
ngũ có hàm cả
quản lý mà ấn vào phần mô tả thì chi
tiết liên hệ quản lý rồi các thứ linh
các thứ thứ tuổi cậu chồng rất chuyên
nghiệp
Ừ thì mình nghĩ là
nếu như bạn đấy làm chắc là có đội ngũ
như thế làm để kiếm tiền đó thì thứ
à à
Ừ thì thì nó khác mình làm được
Lê Thị mình nhiều lúc mình cũng nghĩ
việc phải chỉnh sửa các được chứ nhất là
mình bị lười thứ hai là livestream như
này rồi thì nó nữa lại video luôn thì em
không chỉnh sửa được nhưng mà Nhiều
người bảo là mình làm bosket à những cả
hoặc là làm cái Soft mà kia kìa Thì
đương nhiên thứ nhất là phải cắt ghép
rồi cắt thôi chắc ở trong ghét gì cả
Mình đã nhận cắt cắt một phần của video
hết không có ghét vùng gì cả cho đỡ tốn
công
Ừ nhưng mà
Ừ rồi cơ bản thì mình vẫn bị lừa mấy cái
khoản đấy
Ừ mình đang cân nhắc thời vụ là có khi
phải
máy tuyển nói giống thứ tuyển hơi quá vì
mình từ trước ai mình làm à theo tinh
thần là em tự nguyện là trên hết
để tôi chuẩn bị làm một cái Trang
có nhiều bạn thì biết rồi Tôi có cái
trang cái xinh chọn lọc thức ám chỉ là
Trang chia sẻ ảnh cái sinh thì thì tôi
định làm cái trang tổng hợp tất cả linh
của tất cả các bạn đấy theo dạng là
Ừ ừ
bấm vào ảnh xem được link của bạn đấy
Linh ở đây không phải mỗi Facebook mặc
đầy đủ Linh có thể bạn đấy gần như tranh
về sẽ bế mạng xã hội riêng cho đang Tôi
đang triển khai dần cái vụ đấy rồi Tao
hứa từ năm ngoái rồi đến bây giờ mới bắt
là chuyện ra dần
nó chắc là cái đấy tôi làm Tôi sẽ định
làm miễn phí và cái người làm cùng tôi
người ta cũng
anh cũng kiểu không dám đam mê đâu không
phải đam mê rồi cái sinh tôi nhưng mà
kiểu giận nha họ cũng làm cùng tôi như
miễn phí kiểu gì thế
anh em từ trước may là tôi toàn gạt
người làm cùng một cách kiểu có thể họ
không Cùng đam mê cùng thì tôi truyền
lửa cho họ và họ theo mình
D3 ta sẽ kiếm tôi sẽ cố kiếm một ông là
nó ngồi trình phụ đề hộ tôi
thì tại sao phải có phụ đề về thực ra đã
các bạn của tôi bạn tôi không nghe được
nên là phải dùng phụ đề thêm phụ đề vào
mà mình nghĩ là thêm cuộc đời nó khá hay
a cho video và đứng yên thêm vào vụ cắt
cắt video để mà à
để biến nó thành một cái shop một cái gì
đó nhắn nữa cũng hay à
cho nên Hà bây giờ mình đang nghĩa mình
sẽ có gì Đăng bài kêu gọi
có ai ai muốn làm cùng thì ra là mình
nghĩ về việc là kênh của mình thực ra là
không
30 chưa thực ra chưa đủ mức độ hay nói
là có người tự nguyện làm vụ đấy giống
như kiểu anh đâu Ấn Độ nói cái gì cũng
có về cô cắt hình im hoa cả cắt thành
một đoạn Tâm Sự nhắn đấy về anh nói hay
và nhiều người quan tâm còn bây giờ mình
làm thì
cho mình kiểu thật cáp thì nó hư quá Nó
hơi bé nhưng mà chắc chắn là mình rất
nhỏ bé ở trong cái kiểu
ở trong Việt Nam nói chung thôi
ở những nhưng mà mình vẫn muốn kiểu dạng
là giọt sử là
nếu thật sự là
em thấy mình có vẻ ổn thì tự nhiên mình
muốn lan tỏa không ạ
anh vẫn muốn lan tỏa việc à mình chia sẻ
nó hè có hư hư
anh em vẫn phải cần có người đó Chỉnh
sửa cái đấy xong rồi đăng lên
rất nhiều mạng xã hội Cái vụ đăng lên
nhiều mạng xã hội tôi hệ cốt làm việc à
cắt cắt những cái đoạn làm hay nghỉ Rét
cho nó phải người làm rồi không ạ
à à
em có dạy up close up web lên hot không
ra là
Ê hồi trước mình Định tỉnh các bạn chỉ
các bạn phục đấy nhưng mà ở
xe mình nghĩa là khuyên là chắc là các
bạn cũng phải tự mòm tí Tại sao bởi vì
anh
bởi vì là mình cái giao diện của Cao web
nó hơn khác nhau đến chính bản thân mình
phải tự mò Thời đấy Mình phải tự màu
anh cứ mỗi là giao diện web với giao
diện của cái bên Holcim để mà
Ừ để mà các bạn đầy cốt lên đấy lại khác
nhau nên rất khó để mặc kiểu
cô dạy để cho các bạn đây mình chỉ cần
nói Đại ý là kiểu bản chất nó là gì Các
bạn cậu tự mò để làm nốt thôi
chị xem chắc mình cũng sẽ ghi lại không
ạ Mà thôi bên mình sẽ luôn trả luôn câu
đấy đi
khi chỉnh sửa lại giao diện
Ý bạn là chỉnh sửa lại giao diện về cái
đồ án hay là giao diện cái trang này
trang này là cái Trang à cười shit mà
Google ship mà không ạ
chỉ định
chờ đợi tí mình trả lời từng câu sau nhé
để mình thôi chị các bạn về việc đăng
cốt lên
em thật sự với ba thôi trước thì mình
thuê là Trang hosting girl thì này
Hoặc là các bạn hồi
hồi đầu tiên mình ngồi là mình ngồi mò
thì mình dùng cái trang ah
không có không có ép húc hot này hay
quét phí hot nhỉ Nhiều Lắm
ờ ờ
cái trang này thì để hơn rất nhiều phần
mềm miễn phí cũng như là nó giới hạn cho
cái tài khoản miễn phí ở đại khái bây
giờ mình thử dùng cái hót skincare rồi
nhé
à à
ở đây đầu tiên thì ở đây các bạn sẽ thấy
nó đã có khái niệm về việc là à
đi xe hostting lasting PS awesome đêm
nay Cái này nó là cái gì bản chất là thử
gạ Thực ra ấy thì mình thấy là thực ra
là hai cái hai cái này nó giống nhau à
a cloud cho cá ở bản chất là nó vẫn chỉ
là một cái gọi iCloud
chiều đám mây Không phải mình sẽ sẽ lưu
lại trên đám mây em ạ bị lừa đấy thì ra
cái này là chị ở cái cái nối qua mạng
thôi thì cả hai cái này đều rất giống
nhau là đều cùng cùng lưu lại một chỗ
em không có server ở đó
A và nhưng mà cái xe hot sinh nó sẽ kiểu
bị ngược điện nó làm chưa có một con
server to xong rồi nó sẽ tách rất nhiều
cái hót sinh bé xong rồi mọi người sự
dùng chung với Út Xinh đấy thì cái à
Ừ nếu mà giả sử là cái con nếu mà Giả sử
có một trang ở đó ở trên
áo kiểu Giả sử làm con server nhé Chưa
100 người vô sinh bé sau đó thì một cái
hosting mà tự nhiên kiểu có lượng truy
cập lớn là chết luôn còn server đấy là
chết luôn cả 100 clip sinh cùng trên con
server đấy thế nên là cây xe web hosting
này thử cá nó giải nhất nhưng mà nó
nhược điểm như thế đó là cái tuya các
bạn xem mình nó lúc nào nhưng mà không
giới hạn có thứ được ra bản chất là các
bạn cùng dùng chung tài nguyên với tất
cả trang web khác Chẳng qua tách biệt ra
để mà không ai động vào được ai thôi
Vì thế nên là Ờ nếu mà chuẩn các bạn đến
thuê các bạn nên thuê VPS còn đấy mà các
bạn thực sự không quan tâm đến lưu lượng
kiểu dạng là sự ổn định của trang web
thì các bạn thuê cái này được đón một
các bạn chỉ cần có tổng tí giữ thứ khỏe
khoe bạn bè rồi đăng lên một cái trang
web đó khoe bạn bè đúng không ạ thì dùng
cái này hoặc dùng những cái hót sinh
miễn phí nữa càng tốt
à Còn nếu mà các bạn làm theo cổng là
giống mình đang có một cái tên miền
riêng rồi cái trang kiểu cũng đủ lượng
truy cập ví dụ lịch sử là
ở tầm 100 người vào một lúc thoải mái
lại và nó treo được 24 thì VPS thì nó sẽ
là gì VPS nó bản chất Nó là cái máy tính
nó là Vittel Private thì phải đi chúa
như chúa bị tuồn nó chưa có lại khá là
personal này Server này nghĩa là equate
Private server tất cả kiểu là sơ cá nhân
kiểu của riêng mình và cái v làm chị đã
kết nối từ xa thì thôi Nhấn chỉ ở một
cái con server của riêng mình và kết nối
đưa San bản chất nó giống như là một cái
máy tính của riêng mình các bạn Khuê
giống như thêm một cái máy tính của
riêng mình
hi vọng sẽ có RAM là sẽ có chip bu có
thứ
và mỗi tội là nó được cấu hình theo kiểu
là để mà có thể treo được 24 nhưng mà nó
không có màn hình
thực ra các bạn không cần màn hình gì cả
bản chất là nó nó được cấu hình để mà
các bạn sẽ kết nối bằng chính máy của
bạn lên đấy thì mày làm việc
anh nghe có ông vừa nãy bảo giá treo kèm
cái thường ai treo máy cày game treo này
để làm gì đó với cái này 24 được gần
chết toàn bộ mới cái này hai mươi tư
được thôi Bởi vì nó xinh như bản chất nó
để mà cho cho người khác kết nối lên cái
mạnh cái trang web các bạn mà thì nó
phải luôn hoạt động không ạ với cùng nó
cái Đốm main này thì được à nếu mà các
bạn mà không muốn kiểu thuê không nói
chuyện mua được luôn main chỉ có thuê
Roman thôi nhé ăn chỉ thuê mình cái tên
miền cận như thế này
Ừ thì mất phí có thể là có nhiều trang
thì nó miễn phí khi mà các bạn thuê này
xong tặng thèm cái này nó trang này trả
tiền ít nhưng mà chủ yếu là cứ Giả sử
một trăm nghìn một năm hoạt động sẽ hai
mấy nghìn 1 năm có nếu mà ngoài vài đuôi
kiểu dạng là trầm
xy&z hai cái gì đó nó rẻ hơn nhiều
số chấm com chấm vn lại khát này
nếu không mua được cái chấm edu nhá đầy
đủ không mua rồi đấy thì
cái bản chất là để mà các bạn gõ vào thì
nó sẽ tự nó sẽ điều hướng đến cái hót
sinh các bạn tiện nó nhanh Thôi thay vì
các bạn sẽ phải gõ theo địa chỉ IP giờ
xử là địa chỉ ip của các bạn là cái gì
đó các bạn gõ sửa Mai ip address ạ Ừ cái
đấy bv-6a
Ơ con này đi v4 của tôi nè
đó là sự nhé đứng như các bạn bè Gõ cái
này lên thành địa chỉ thị 03 được mày
tôi đâu
Ừ đấy kìa bạn bản chất là tôi không
không mở cái nối là địa chỉ ipv4 này
mình nhớ không lầm nữa không phải thêm
và cái gì đó nữa cơ thì mới vào được cơ
nhưng mà đại khái là người dùng không Có
nhớ vị trí ở trang web học các bạn nên
là các bạn sẽ thường lại mua domain Nếu
các bạn hiểu cốt để làm mục đích cá nhân
thôi Thực ra các bạn chẳng cần phải thuê
cái này trái và tiếp theo đó nữa đó là
chỉ khi mà các bạn thuê xong rồi thì các
bạn sẽ Cấu hình nó đúng không ạ kéo sinh
của tôi à đúng ơi tôi không dùng cái
sinh bên này nữa
tôi nhớ xem mà bộ phim Việt Nam Luật sư
cái
tội mua một cái miễn phí à
ở không mà không phải miễn phí mà tôi
mua hôm Black Ra đây 3 triệu nhưng dùng
chọn đôi ạ sau đó tôi
hơn hay nằm ở Tôi không động ở đây nữa
nhưng đại khái thì bên bên này tôi tôi
đang Facebook sinh cái này nên tôi xin
phép lại đăng nhập lại bằng bên anh nhé
ờ ờ
ở đây
A S D D 10gb 10gb máy ông ruột gà Nó lớn
lắm nó không có hệ điều hành gì mấy
Ừ vậy thì có cái khái niệm C3 này từ
cpanel các bạn
các bạn sẽ cấu hình các thử trong này
ở đầu tiên là cấu hình về cả menu này
file này các bạn sẽ băng file lên ở Farm
another này hoặc hoặc là thường mà sẽ ăn
sẽ dùng stp account này FTP AK này tất
cả ấy chị đã các bạn thay vì các bạn cứ
cứ mỗi lần muốn để Út mới lên thì có bạn
lại vào trang này thôi vào cái cái đường
link này không cần mà các bạn sẽ làm ở
gì Các bạn sẽ
thì các bạn sẽ tạo một tài khoản FPT Sau
đó các bạn tải cái file zilla
Ừ nè đấy
ạ sau đó thì các bạn sẽ đầy con lên bằng
cái này nhưng mà cái này chỉ phù hợp với
việc à
các bạn đẩy lên những cốt mới và những
cốt mà các bạn kiểu làm có mấy nghìn vai
rồi đến chục nghìn file rồi thì cái việc
7 lên bằng cái này nói rất là lâu cái
cái này để từng file ấy một thì đầu tiên
là khi mà các bạn có hẳn có sẵn một đống
vai rồi đấy các bạn nên nén nó lại nè
lại và dặn Zip nhé Rồi các bạn lên đây
để
Ừ để mà bằng tải lên cho nó giải nén ra
trước đã đấy sau đó ý những cái file mới
thì các bạn mới dùng cái này để đẩy Cốt
Đây ạ gì đấy kinh nghiệm của mình làm
thôi mình mình thì K mình bảo mình không
hẳn là chuyên làm mấy cái này bởi vì
mình làm từ trước này mục đích cá nhân
nếu mục đích kinh doanh hay hay làm gì
ghê gớm nhà mình chỉ tìm hưởng mức tương
đối là chạy được còn các bạn là mà có
kinh nghiệm hơn mình Các bạn cứ chia sẻ
nhé
tiếp theo là các bạn có phân biệt đã có
7 để mà kết nối ra sân bay hoặc như thế
này như thế này cũng được đóng lại
ừ ừ
Ừ tôi Đúng là có thể dùng ít nhỉ quên
đấy nhưng mà tôi tôi bảo rồi Thật là Hồi
đấy tôi kém ít Tôi không động ngồi bên
nghĩ thật hôi hôi rồi đấy Tôi không nhớ
cái bên hotgirl nó có từ ít cơ không
nhưng không có bây giờ thì tôi thấy ạ Ở
đâu có nhắc đến ký rồi nhưng thời ấy như
không có
Ừ thôi năm nhất của tôi cái gì thì tôi
chẳng nhớ cái cùng gì cả
Ừ ok xài ghép được thì cứ ghi dấu nhất
mà nó đỡ phải thì mình chỉ cần có mít
các thứ thứ mình đỡ phải kêu tải file gì
là về cũng được đấy nhưng đại khái gì
thì mình vừa nói qua một loạt đấy đó làm
chị à các bạn sẽ phải thuê một cái con
gì đó chứ không phải để Cốc trên máy
mình rồi người khác cái nối được đối
ngoại
sau đó đi các bạn sẽ đầy cốt lên là bao
nhiêu người khác thì truy cập được thôi
Nếu mà chính vì người khác truy cập được
nên là mày ông Chánh đừng như tôi hồi
trước tôi tôi còn Lỡ để cái file Cấu
hình nó thiếu thứ mà không hề
xét lại quyền nên thành ra lạ có ông vào
ngồi xem được
a-data bay thứ tư thế 001
anh em béo phải kiểm tra lại kỹ các
quyền cá từ thứ quyền file không cho
truy cập các thứ cái đấy sẽ liên quan
đến HT access thì tôi sẽ dậy vào
khóa sau
em gà tội thì dậy ở mức tương đối thôi
tôi cục nhá
ở lại cũng không tìm hiểu cái đấy lắm
ở thời thượng cái đấy thường chúng ta
chỉ làm mà một lần cấu hình một lần là
được
nụ hôn bây giờ mình sẽ trả lời các câu
hỏi nữa nhé
ẩm thực gà tôi còn chưa tổng hợp
Ừ tôi chưa tổng hợp câu hỏi của Bộ hôm
trước nữa cơ Thôi bảo Tuấn cái cuối tuần
của tôi khá lừa à
Ừ anh có thể cho em một phô đờ ray em sẽ
cắt vi giao rồi gửi gửi lên đó
Ừ ừ
Mình định đăng hẳn một cái bài đăng này
mà kêu gọi có một một vài một thực ra
chỉ cần một người cũng được mà quan
trọng là ở
thì các bạn cắt theo ý các bạn thì thực
ra là cũng cũng cũng được nhưng mà Thì ý
mình là mình sẽ trao đổi thường xuyên
với bạn đấy vào đây làm cùng một hoặc
hai người không ạ
are you YouTube còn tự nguyện làm thì à
nữa Hai nữa dò nữa đâu lại lại
Các bạn thấy hay nhưng mà mình thấy có
gì đó Sai sai à
anh
chia sẻ suy nghĩ về lĩnh vực bác em
em không biết à chia sẻ cái gì tại Khá
gì à Nếu Như Ý của bạn là chỉ là bác em
có có hót hay không thì chắc chắn là
ngày này thì cái dịp đang hót cả à
à Còn nếu mà hỏi về cái mức độ cụ mức độ
khó của nó thì chắc cho nó bác em nó sẽ
khó cho nên bây giờ chủ yếu con mẹ nó có
xử lý ở bên ferrer rồi
Ừ anh có dùng tôi còn chả biết cái kia
là cái gì nên chắc là không rồi
Ừ nếu là 1 web xem phim thì mình dùng gì
để lưu chí phim cái câu hỏi này cũng khá
hay bởi vì thường là giống như hôm trước
tôi nói về cái kiểu trang web của mình
là mình sẽ tải ảnh của người dùng lên
khi mà người dùng đăng ảnh lên thì mình
lưu lại ảnh trên server đúng ạ
nhưng còn phim mình nặng hơn rất rất
nhiều nên là và giống như vừa rồi mấy
ông thấy là cái con hoc sinh của tôi chỉ
có 10 giây thôi người ghi thôi ông ạ
ạ Bây giờ là sự có hai bộ hai bộ phim
full HD hết sự dung lượng rồi Thế bây
giờ mình sẽ phải làm như thế nào mình
thuê có server nhiều dung lượng hơn à
không không ở Hồi trước và rất nhiều vậy
Trang hết xinh nó chơi cho đó là
nó đăng lên Google Drive Hồi đấy còn có
cái vụ Google Drive Unlimited nữa
khi họ sẽ Đang nghe Google Drive sau đó
thì nó sẽ ở chung là nó cũng mò kiểu gì
để lấy được cái
đấy được
Cậu dặn là link trực tiếp được đến cái
Google Drive thế là nó hoàn thành ra là
kiểu Nó gần như có một cái
server riêng này là Đặng Đền mà lưu lại
phim ở trên Google Drive Tự nhiên bây
giờ Gold nó cấm nổi mình không nhớ
người ta sẽ áp dụng bằng cách nào nhưng
chắc chắn là việc thuê sinh riêng để mà
lưu ở Đồng file như thế ở nó không khả
thi lắm với nó sẽ rất nặng nhiều
A fallen có phổ biến không ạ Có chứ
cho tôi bảo ngành nào bây giờ trong
ngành Công nghệ thông tin thì gửi cái gì
phổ biến thôi Wattpad
có bạn từng hỏi mình về web này
khi mình còn chưa định nghĩa được rõ cái
phát này là gì
Ẩm Thực sự thì đôi khi là các bạn không
Mình mình nghĩa là từ ra có những cái
khái niệm mà thật ra là mình tiếp xúc
hàng ngày nên tôi nhưng đôi khi mình
cũng chẳng chẳng biết được nó là thật nó
là thế cơ
không biết trả lời mấy câu này như nào ạ
ô tô zend Tao đây là nó giả khác
biết bạn ở coron này đúng không
Đây này một dẫn khác
không không không phải ý mình người cái
phim vừa rồi to their cỡ đâu
Ờ Ờ
thôi mình sẽ trả lời những câu hỏi ở đây
nữa nhá Sau đó gì hôm nay vào buổi học
ra hôm nay bài học hôm nay thì cũng ngắm
thôi không không không dài lắm cũng
không hẳn là khó lắm Nó gọi là mở rộng
thêm một tí thêm một tí tính năng và cho
bạn hiểu rõ vì việc à cơ chế gửi mail
cũng như là cấu hình 33 như thế nào để
gửi mail đóng ngoặc ạ ở đầu tiên thì nói
về cũng trước có bạn hỏi vụ là ờ
để lưu lại nhiều thông tin trong cùng 1
cột Thực ra thì
cái bài toán ở đây nó sẽ là như thế này
nó là thừa nhận thì nhất là nó vi phạm
với quy tắc mà quy chuẩn của thiết kế cơ
sở liệu như mình từng nói thì một cột
không nên có chứa nhiều giá trị đóng
ngoặc
ở những Nếu giả sử là kiểu các bạn không
Muốn tách nó ra hẳn một cái bảng riêng
bởi vì ấm chỉ là ở
hai tay như này đi mình sẽ cứ dùng các
bạn thẳng ngay cho dễ hiểu
A
Sử có bảng nhà sản phẩm
bỏ qua tất cả cột khác sự đây Hồi trước
mình đã từng nói về vụ là là sử mình có
cấu hình thằng ạ
cơ cấu hình của một sản phẩm ra sự máy
tính đi đúng không ạ thì như hôm trước
mình có nói thì là sửa RAM thì sẽ là 4
GB em ạ không ạ
ở đây đang sửa thêm một cột nữa đấy cho
rõ đi
tên sản phẩm là sự là tên sản phẩm lại
là laptop gì đó không ạ thì cấu hình ở
đây sẽ bao gồm gram bao nhiêu này xong
rồi phải ở đây à chạy mình sẽ dùng phải
ở đây để mà nắp sữa mấy học đó ngoại
giao sự ram như này rồi màn hình trở lại
màn hình này
là ips trả lại
rồi Như ạ bại khai đại khái như thế ra ở
cái kiểu này kiểu đa Chị ở trong ở trong
cơ sở liệu
khi đóng ạ nghĩa các bạn sẽ tách nhau
từng giá trị một thứ nhất à Để tên của
tên của cái cấu hình này xong rồi giá
trị của cấu hình này cách nhau bởi dấu
hai chấm trắng ạ đóng ngoặc vừa rồi mình
có làm như này bị Hơi sai tự nhiên mình
thưa dấu cách ở đây Chính vì cái thừa do
cách nào trước thì nó cốt mình cũng có
thể bị lỗi bởi việc giá trị tự nhiên có
thêm dù cách mà lại giá trị nó phải như
thế này cơ mà đương nhiên là các bạn
thấy việc
Ừ để người dùng bắt buộc người dùng phải
nhập Đúng là kẹo không có dấu cách này
không thừa này sau đó thì nhập tên của
tên của thuộc tính sau đó huy giá trị
như thế này rất nhiều người dùng nhập
nhưng ta tinh và đúng là có nhiều trang
web người dùng nhập kinh tăng thật các
bạn ấn vào xem cái thông số kỹ thuật của
một vài kênh bán laptop và phụ kiện
đã mang tiếng ở cùng một loại laptop
ở cùng cùng loại là laptop nhé nhớ ở nơi
thông số kỹ thuật hứng lên thì nó ghi là
cấu hình thông số kỹ thuật là một kiểu
thôi không thèm nhìn một điều tôi không
rõ là kinh nhà thử ví dụ An Phát rồi em
ạ Không không biết có bị không mấy kính
lớn thì còn chuẩn chuẩn tí kính phụ kênh
kênh nhỏ không Tí à cái thông số nó loạn
hết cả lên luôn mang tiếng ở cùng một
cái laptop
hoài mong tiếng cùng là laptop
Ừ cái thông số mà tôi đang nói à là mấy
cái bên bên trái này
Ừ ừ trong cái này có vẻ quy chuẩn à
Em có nhớ hôm trước ở đây ở đây có một
vài cái cơ hướng lên ví dụ một cái đơn
giản nữa nhé đó là
có người ghi ở bộ nhớ thôi xong rồi mở
ngoặc Loan sao hôm sau lại hứng lên rồi
ghi bộ nhớ trong được mở ngoặc ram đấy
nó đã khác rồi Nếu mà theo như cốt mình
các bạn hiểu rồi nó là khác rồi đúng
không ạ xong rồi có những người ghi ổ
đĩa sau đó đi giá trị của nó bên này là
là OD chẳng ạ Đấy có người yêu ổ đĩa
Quang thôi không ngờ này nó lại là một
cái khác rồi đúng ạ
Ừ cái việc và để mà cháu người dùng nhập
đúng như thế thứ nhất là mình phải có
quy ước tất cả các cấu hình trước chứ
không để cho người dùng tự nhập cái tên
của cấu hình là một thứ hai là nếu và
làm như thế này thì bây giờ giờ sự là
đấy Bây giờ mình ấn vào ấn vào những cái
laptop có có RAM là như thế nào đấy bộ
nhớ trong là như thế nào để như này như
này đúng ạ thì chắc chắn nó sẽ khó mà
Phi tơ được Nó khó mà lọc được không có
que đoạn weather này sẽ khó que đoạn này
như nào Ông định quay đoạn này như thế
nào cũng sẽ quay nha
que cấu hình like
này
làm
64GB cả nhà
ở phần trăm phần trăm ngay xong ngồi
and thôi Cấu hình lại like như này tiếp
à không không không ai làm như này cả
ở
lại màn hình đúng ạ màn hình
à à
ở đây như nè
Không ai làm như thế nên là
thường là ít nơi làm thì cậu đang chị Ba
chị vào trong cái cột đương nhiên thì
mình dùng từ ít nơi ở vị trí cao chính
công ty mình hàng nếu mà công ty mình
làm và mình quy chuẩn luôn cái việc Tên
một toàn bộ Cái này là quy tên của thấu
kính nó quy chuẩn thôi à thường là mình
không Peter không Peter theo cái cột này
mà mình chỉ đơn giản à Lưu lại để hiển
thị toàn bộ cái đấy ra khi mình mới lưu
lại trong một cột Còn nếu mà mình mà
Twitter Twitter nghĩa lọc nước lọc dữ
liệu theo cột này thì mình nên tách ra
như hôm trước mình có nói đó là giờ sự
là cấu hình sản phẩm đầu tiên là cấu
hình đã nhưng mình không chưa có nói nó
là thật sự là mã này
một này tên này ram này hay
ở màn hình ngày đó ngoại
sau đó thì có một bảng trung gian mà bạn
cấu hình sản phẩm à
ý là mã sản phẩm
mã số hình
đây là một này một này 42 hiểu là sôi
giá trị
về mình hiểu là ok với con laptop có mã
là một Nó sẽ có cô cấu hình Ram nối này
biết Cấu hình ra nữa giá trị là 40 ạ Các
bạn thích cái ghi thêm đơn vị ở đây được
đơn vị là cậu đơn vị là gì đấy đúng ạ
thường ghi đơn vị có thể ghi đơn vị ở
ngay trong này thì nó ổn hơn
ghi là đóng ngoặc
anh ấy Tùy các bạn
xe mình nghĩa tách hẳn gì trong ngày để
đỡ phải lặp lại ở đây hơn đó thì như này
nó sẽ dễ hơn rẻ hơn khá nhiều còn không
thì ông ghi hẳn giá trị 4G RAM nhạc cũng
được
Ừ Ok Nhưng mày không hiểu thì tôi về cái
vụ đa chị nào ông ạ
ờ ờ tiếp theo đó là
thì các bạn sẽ
các bạn làm đồ án Các bạn nhớ phải làm
thêm tính năng là xem đơn đã đặt ở bến
khách hàng nhé
cô còn thử cái này thì khá là dễ thôi Nó
giống hệt cái Hiển thị danh hiển thị cái
Nghe danh sách đơn và đơn chi tiết ở bên
admin chẳng qua là mình sẽ welter mã
khách hàng đã đăng nhập nữa có nhiều xem
được thì thôi
a tiếp theo là có bạn hỏi câu này có một
form có hai nút để khi mà sắp ít
ừ thì bấm vào nút này thì sẽ nhảy sang
file sắp ít sang file này còn bấm vào
nút kia thì sắp mít sắp ít nhé chứ không
phải là đường Linh thẻ để mà nhảy nhảy
xem file nào đó đâu bây giờ sắp ít Ừ thì
thơ ca bài toán ở đây
vì nó không Thứ nhất là không thể theo
quy tắc thiết theo quy tắc chuẩn thì nó
không nên vào khó không lên đấy không
phải không thể đó là không nên để cho
khi mà khi mà kiểu dạng là một mục
format của
một form nó bản chất là các bạn nhớ nó
chỉ có một cái á chân để nhảy đến một
cái file đó thôi ông ạ
cho các bạn nhiều lắm
Ừ thế để mình mở Cố lên nhé
à à
nhà mình có cái Tết đi có tên mà lồi này
còn nhớ thẻ for không ạ thì bản cho thẻ
phòng có một cái chân mình ấy đến một
cái file cụ thể đó thôi không nói chuyện
là cái bút Tân nó sẽ là hai cho với việc
là nó sẽ ghi đè lên các trường này
đổ ngoạn nhưng mà đương nhiên là mình
vẫn có thể can thiệp được bằng chính da
Suite để làm điều này mình sẽ on click ở
đây là
oneclick là khi mà bấm vào cái nút này
là sự đấy nút a ạ Click vào nút A thì nó
sẽ gọi đến cái hàm để mà ghi đề ấy ác
triển của cái phone này nhớ đến cái file
pei nhận Còn khi bấm vào nút B thì mình
sẽ ghi đè lên gác trên đây nhảy đến
tt3b nhân thường mình thấy ạ Không không
nơi áo dụng đầy lắm
300 lên
ở đây là kiểu không Mình thấy cái việc
là một phom có hai nút để nhảy sang Hifi
nghe không khả thi
để nó sắp mít su mít chứ không phải
người xa nhảy sang lời nói chuyện thấy a
thôi còn đây sắp mít xanh này mình thấy
không khả thi
a tiếp theo ở có bạn hôm trước hỏi mấy
cái vụ lấy lại dữ liệu không cần bác áp
Ừ thì à
Ừ mình thì không biết thằng SR cơ chế
như thế nào nhưng mà nhiều bên hosting
còn nói chung ấy hoặc cả trình máy tính
các bạn nói chung ấy các bạn Các bạn có
xem đến bộ phim Cảnh Sát Hình Sự Cái vụ
mà
đầu tiên thì ông lợn ông et à Ông ấy Xóa
Xóa toàn bộ dữ liệu đi rồi sau đó khi ạ
Ông kia bảo là tháo cứng thường nói đốt
rồi cắm lại tự nhiên thế rồi ngồi gỗ gõ
một tí thể khôi phục lại dữ liệu ông ạ
Ông nhìn có biết được cái đoạn video là
em ạ Video Huyền Thoại
à à
Ừ thì thì nhiều người sẽ bảo là kìa hóa
ra đốt ổ cứng thì sẽ khôi phục dữ liệu
nhưng nhưng mà thật là không phải dàn mà
Mấy ông biết được điều đấy không phải
đúng ạ
có
chạy án Việt Anh
đốt lốp cực
từ khóa trả
36 phút cả thôi Không không xem cho vui
đó
Chồng nghĩ hiểu vậy chưa
ở đây nhờ nó chút là đại khái mày ông
nếu mà ông ấy chưa xem thì nghe Tôi tóm
tắt nó như thế
thì đầu tiên này mày không phải hiểu về
vụ là máy tính khi mà xóa dữ liệu lịch
đi không có nghĩa là không có nghĩa là
dữ liệu bị mất đi thực sự À mà bạn bản
chất là nó vẫn thể khôi phục được Bởi vì
khi mà xóa dữ liệu đi thì nó là cho phép
dữ liệu khác có thể ghi đè nó vào mùa
khi mà dữ liệu khác chưa ghi để nó thì
nó vẫn còn ở đó và hoàn toàn khôi phục
được ờ ờ
Vì thế nên là các bạn vẫn thể tải được
nhiều phần mềm về để khôi phục nếu là sử
các bạn lỡ xoá cái đi trên máy tính kể
cả dù các bạn xóa nó khỏi thùng rác các
bạn cũng khôi phục được
thế nên là cũng mới có sinh ra cái vụ
này nghe vụ này thì trông nó đương nhiên
này phim mà nó kiểu gì sẽ cố là nấu lên
đấy ông ạ
và tương tự Thế bên Nếu mà giờ sử các
bạn thôi Ở bên hosting có sự thứ Thực ra
người ta lại có một cách khác
con gà không hạn áp dụng cách đấy nhưng
mà người ta vẫn thường hay có cái gói
gọi là lưu lại em hỗ trợ các bạn lưu lại
24 giờ một lần cả cơ sở điệu cả cốt các
thứ để các bạn Khôi phục lại còn nếu là
sử các bạn không gọi này thì các bạn vẫn
inbox nhiều vải lấy hàng cái đã khôi
phục cho và cái việc khôi phục người ta
sẽ làm chính là cái một mình vừa nói đó
có thể là ra dùng chạy tool gì đó để
khôi phục lại một phần ở trên đấy nó về
mặt một lý mà một phần dữ liệu và anh
nói chuyện một phần thôi mà sẽ không
được đầy đủ
Vì thế nên là tấn tự giống như gần đây
mình cũng có có lỡ xóa nhân một vài kể ở
trong vụ trong thư mục Google Google
Drive sau đó thì mình mình nhắn tin nó
support
à mình mình khuyên các bạn nếu giờ sự
các bạn mà ở không đi lại đi làm rồi
không có lỡ diễn viên kìa kiểu nói chung
à gọi có điều kiện hơn một tí không ạ
thì các bạn nên
nên mua về gọi Google one này
a good One thứ nhất là
Ừ tôi quảng cáo Google Nhưng mà Xuka à
em gà tội thích Google Nhưng mà từ Tao
chẳng được gì cả thì thôi chị còn cả
quảng cáo không phải quảng cáo mà chia
sẻ anh em về cái vụ này
ê chó đó là cái thằng Google này nói để
tăng cái Dung lượng Google Drive Lên
Thực ra nhiều người thấy kiểu
dùng OneDrive còn rẻ hơn nữa vân vân
Nhưng tôi nói cái lợi ích mà Tôi thấy
của thằng Google này mà mày cũng không
biết được nhé
Ngoài việc là nó thể hỗ trợ các bạn à
vân vân Nhưng nó đã nói ở trong này các
bạn ở đọc qua các bạn cứ đẹp qua đã xem
nó có gì hay nhưng cái nhấn mạnh của tôi
thích đó là cái này
cái hai cục này đúng là chỉ tôi
Ừ tôi có biết rằng mấy ông mấy ông kêu
tận dụng hay không nhưng mà chị tôi áp
dụng trò đó là nó khi mà trả tiền nó nó
nó có trò đây nó có hết
Ê bà chat được trực tiếp với Google
ở đây
anh có chat trực tiếp với Google có
thiếu thứ
A và đúng là nhân viên Google hỗ trợ tôi
luôn
Vì thế nên là rất nhiều lúc tôi hỏi là
tôi nhắn tin hỏi nó được ví dụ giống như
tôi vừa rồi anh nhắn tin trực tiếp
em chat với nó không phải nó không Chắc
là lại bằng boss rồi nhé Chắc là lại vào
người thật cái này đều rất là Hiển khi
mà nó trong chẳng qua là thằng Google nó
không phổ biến nhưng xảy ra nó vẫn còn
như thế ra sự nó như là thằng Facebook
toàn bộ là tự động hết toàn bộ nó boss
hết thì thì lại giờ thì tôi nhiều lúc
ngờ và nó rất nhiều
Ừ nếu mình thực sự các bạn mà cảm thấy
các bạn dùng Google nhiều và gặp khá
nhiều vấn đề như nó giống như hôm trước
tôi lại nhắn nó nó hỏi về vấn đề bên
YouTube chẳng hạn họ sẽ có hỗ trợ của
tôi tất cả vụ đấy
Ừ cái hay phết lợi ích để tôi nghĩa là
không không phải ai cũng dùng nhiều thầy
ra nó vẫn chơi người thật nếu hơn sự ai
cũng lạm dụng nó giống như thằng
Facebook trí cơ Bây giờ ấy thì nó sẽ
chắc là chuyển dần sang boss hoặc cả gửi
mail tự động
tôi đứng như là đấy gì ở bộ phận hỗ trợ
thôi chứ bộ phận này không phải bộ phận
A đúng rồi mấy lần bộ phận hỗ trợ không
trả được cơ xong rồi tôi tôi tôi nói thế
xong đấy nó vấn đề rồi Xong ấy họ còn
gọi là tích của bên họ sang nhưng mà cái
cái việc họ gọi tax anh ấy đó là họ có
có cảm thấy kiểu phù hợp để gọi cách 20
nhiều lúc họ cứ bảo là tôi sẽ gửi lại
cái lỗi này cho tách các thứ thứ nhưng
có mấy lần họ còn gọi tách vào để trả
lời cho tôi thế thế nên mấy kiểu thấy
cái giá trị giá trị Tôi Thuê về Google
one girl là mình đã sử dụng tới tất cả
những cái tiện ích của nó rồi vào chị có
bốn chín nghìn một tháng nó không nên
lỗi bắt nó tắt so với người hiểu đi làm
lương diễn 10 cũ thì nó chẳng đã Thời
đại không ạ Nhưng cái vụ là có một ông
tá Ừ để báo hỗ trợ cho ông nói một vấn
đề khác giá trị lớn hơn rất nhiều ạ
và mẹ brahman quá thôi tiếp hôm trước
hôm trước là có một bạn nhắn tin Bố của
tôi bảo là em được top 1 nha Bởi vì anh
để lộ để ID của Cao hút nên em để em
biết được em hack
Thực ra tôi vẫn bảo bạn đấy là Ok em Nếu
như thế thì ra em vẫn áp dụng công nghệ
thông tin để mà
để mà
gọi là Thắng thì thì anh vẫn cầu
ế vẫn hoàn toàn vui vẻ kiểu đi cà phê
các thử thôi nhưng mà tôi tin là nhiều
ông ở đây sẽ cay cay thì kiểu mình bị
cực cửa mất tốt cái tốt một đấy đến nhà
ông ấy Mình chỉ à Làm thêm một phát thôi
Ừ nhưng mà hình như là tôi cũng chỉ nhớ
có đúng Có đúng một cái á
số
111 lần á
Mấy ông được điểm tuyệt đối nhưng mà
thời hạn nhiều ông lúc đấy cũng được
điểm tuyệt đối
cho nên Đây là kẹo mình nghĩ là
ok
họ cũng công bằng một phần như cỡ
những ông kia cũng được điểm tuyệt đối
rồi bây giờ sự là những ông kia điểm ở
vị chênh lệch quá là sửa ông mới trả lời
được 10 câu trên 13 câu hỏi dạng nạn mà
ông ấy đúng hết 13:13 chỉ ca hơi say
không ạ
Ừ ừ thì tôi thử cái tôi không hả mà
không thích mấy ông nên dùng hết khùng
gì cả nhưng mà bởi vì là tôi dạy về lập
trình
ông đấy áp dụng lập trình để mà thắng
thì đấy cũng là một cái
A gọi như nào
anh Bởi vì lúc đấy mình đang thi thi
theo hình thức là
áp dụng kiến thức mà ngoại nên là tôi
thấy thời ra vẫn phù hợp một phần thôi
nhưng nhiều nơi nó sẽ không đồng ý điều
đấy đâu ạ
a tiếp theo có hôm trước mình có đang về
này trên A cái Fanpage của mình ra cô
vẫn có bạn bị bị nhầm là mình cho xem
lại các bạn cái anh ấy có hai điều khó ở
trong lập trình
12 điều khó nhất ở trong liệu trình
anh alo hay bị khó rồi
thì mình đã dịch nó đây rồi một phần là
à bắt đầu từ không ạ Không là
3 cách in very spacious kaki
Ừ cái này tôi dịch ra lưu cách hợp lý
các bạn nhờ cái cách cái gì không ạ thì
thì bản chất
các bạn khi mà các bạn loạt một cái
trang nào đó các bạn thấy Loan ở rất là
lâu sau đó tải lại trang để thấy nó
nhanh hơn về bản chất là nó lưu cách lại
rồi đừng ôm trước mình từng nói về cái
vụ thế giới di động này ạ
cách làm trang 1,4 giây này Tại sao này
từ 1,2
từ 0,9 Các bạn thấy cày vàng nhanh dần
bởi vì nó đã lưu cách lại rồi thế là nó
lưu lại nó lưu lại cả
lưu lại cả trên fernand nhưng mà Thậm
chí nó lưu lại cả bác em mua vài cái nữa
Ừ thì cà phê cải cách như hội nhưng mà
phải gọi lưu hợp lý Tại sao bộ vì nhiều
cái thì nó không hay nó thường xuyên
thay đổi thì các bạn không hẳn nên lưu
lại nói chung các bạn với lưu điều chỉnh
sao cho phù hợp và sự là cái bác và xử
với ba nơi ạ thì một ngày 21 lần này thì
các bạn nên lưu cách trong thời gian một
ngày nhưng có những cái khác thì nó sẽ
trả mưa thay đổi sự cái logo rồi trả lời
hồ cạn thì bạn lên cách vĩnh viễn cũng
được lại khá nó như thế Nói chung là lưu
cách này nó bài toán rất là đau đâu các
bạn về sau làm các bạn sẽ biết
A2 extension petrotimes
ờ ờ
a tiếp theo là đặt tên mọi thứ
Ờ Ờ kệ cài đặt tên này thứ ba Các bạn sẽ
không phải đặt tên cho cả
cài đặt tên cho cả biến này là tên cho
các file này tên các thư mục được tên
Nói chung là tên cho mọi thứ trong lập
trình thực ra là như mình đã nói
Ừ nó là vừa đọc cái là phải hiểu được
ngay
Ừ nhưng mà đôi khi là cái biến các bạn
mà dài quá thì nó dễ hiểu thì ra thành
ra khó nhớ và bị nhầm lẫn này cái để cân
bằng được cả hai cái này rất khó
hai
số tự nhiên đang từ một lại nhảy sang
cái bẫy cái 7 nó liên quan đến bất đồng
bộ cái này thử ca trong pp mình ngày mai
ra không dính Nhưng ở trong ngôn ngữ lập
trình khác thì nó sẽ có
già sự nhựa sava is a sweet cây bất đồng
bộ Tức là sao nghĩa là giả sử các bạn mở
hai cái điếu cày BP nó theo quy tắc là
cái này chạy Xong thì cái kia mày chạy
là sự bé ở tôm ở hai cái tắc hay tác
Facebook ạ là sự cái tác Facebook này
cho lót xong top Facebook bên này đã lót
được xong rồi nên nó độc lập hay cái thể
được gọi cùng một lúc nhưng mà không có
tâm hàng nào chạy trước chạy sau khi
thằng kia mới chạy được ạ Máy tôi còn
bao nhiêu RAM thì hoàn toàn thể mở được
bấy nhiêu Tab mà mấy và tất cả những Tab
này nó sẽ chạy độc lập không ạ Nó có ảnh
hưởng với nhau không nói chuyện là khi
mình chạy xong thằng này thì thằng kia
Mày chạy đấy đấy Cái về cái bất đồng bộ
và cái đồng bộ như thế
Thế theo là lỗi xin lỗi liên quan đến
việc điểm từ 020 lúc bị Đếm từ không Lúc
đến từ một thực ra thì
khi đôi khi ở lập trình viên Mình thường
hay bị bối rối cái này thường này quy
ước là đến chứ không Nếu từ từ mà nhưng
có những cái khác là người lập trình
viên đến từ mục khá nhanh đôi khi nó
sinh ra những cái lỗi cửa ngoài ăn kiểu
như thế
em có bạn hỏi ở đây này có bạn hỏi là
có hai cái khó nhưng mà lại thấy ở đây
có bảy cái thì còn bốn gái con lại đâu
các bạn ấy bị nhầm đó thực ra đây chẳng
qua là cái thực ra nó vẫn là hai cái khó
thôi nhưng thứ nhất là mình đến được
không Thứ hai là bởi vì nó bất đồng bộ
này là
cho nên lòi ra một con số ở đó ngẫu
nhiên ở đây và nhưng mà đến mắt của mình
vẫn trẻ hay thôi Thế nên mới thành ra là
chỉ có hai cái khó
a mắt một mình hay
Có ai ở mấy ông điểm tổng đâu đúng không
ạ mắc mình hay mình sẽ nói hai cái khó
thôi
anh Bởi vì nó bất đồng bộ nó xem nó giữa
đề ngoại
Ừ nếu muốn chưa hiểu cái đùi cũng đừng ạ
Hoàng Sa kiểu định sẽ hiểu thôi
Ừ tí mèo hôm trước
còn chưa kìa do chính thằng get nó gợi ý
Vậy có bạn làm trong đồ án bạn đấy Kiểu
dùng get comment chứ không dùng cái get
đấy top mà tôi hướng dẫn mấy ông nhà nên
dùng cái tít top này cái ghi đem tốt và
ý nghĩa các bạn không cần phải gõ
comment thứ hai là
như tôi nói nó sẽ phải Pu về và bút lên
nói chung rất Nó khó mà bị có vụ này xảy
ra vụ đấy là bạn ấy phút để cốt nên
không được cho thằng ghi là gợi ý là
dụng cái Fox nghĩa là để Apple đẩy lên
thì đầy được mà Đúng là lấy được nhưng
cũng chọn được ghi đè lên cốt của ông
kia Bởi vì đơn giản bạn ấy cho làm bạn
phải Quẹo Cốt về mới về đấy mới đầy cốt
mới lên được nhưng mà không bạn không
kéo về bạn ơi đẩy đẩy lên ghi đè lên
file đó Xóa luôn cả cột cụ cố của ông
kia à Ừ nè Tôi khuyên mấy ông đừng có
đừng có chạy mấy cái lệnh gì đó mà mình
không nắm rõ như thế đừng nghe nó gợi ý
cái áp dụng không ạ Mày không phải Hiệp
còn không thì tôi bảo dùng cái đít đã
viết top của tôi cho dễ hiểu à
từ hạt điều muốn ngồi có tay nhiều sướng
á
thì tại sao tại sao thế nhỉ Nếu không
lừa như tôi vậy
a tiếp theo à
cho các bạn khi mà viết tài liệu trong
cái đồn ấy thì các bạn không nên khi rất
nhiều rất dài dòng toàn bộ những cái
tính năng nâng cao mà các bạn không là
các bạn và không ghi được cái tính năng
mà không phải tự mình làm dù ở sự như là
chắt bóp
hoặc là
thì các bạn nhúng bình luận từ Facebook
về thì các bạn không thể có tính năng
bình luận
à Hôm trước có bạn bảo là có cả gọi
ý nghĩa là nếu mà một khi các bạn có cả
tính năng gọi là các bạn phải tự làm từ
đầu đến cuối cái tính năng đấy và gọi
được gửi trên trang web các bạn chứ
không phải là các bạn để số điện thoại
để khách hàng có thật gọi và các bạn
kiểu đấy tính áp cái đấy ngoài tính năng
đúng ạ
ở đây là các bạn cái tài liệu phải sửa
lại vụ này cho mình nhá
tiếp theo
có bạn hôm trước cũng hỏi về cái vụ
Ừ cái vụ đồng bộ giỏ hàng em vào em vào
shopee em đạt một vài sản phẩm trong giỏ
hàng sau đó thì em vào bằng máy khác em
thấy rõ hành với vẫn còn
thì cái này bài toán là nó không đem cái
lưu lại cái giỏ hàng đấy nó không lưu
lại trong sân mà nó lưu lại trong chính
data-page
Anh ở trong bạn order và các bạn có thể
thêm 1 cột nữa là cột là thứ cột cái cột
status trạng thái của cái order lại cũng
cũng có rồi các bạn chỉ cần thêm cái là
kiểu thêm một trạng thái là chưa đặt
à mà trạng thái đã đặt thì vẫn như cũ
thôi cái chưa đặt Tức là nó nằm trong
giỏ Hà còn đã làm tồi nó sẽ vứt xó A gọi
gió hàng để nó một cách để các bạn lưu
lại giỏ hàng trong gió mây
à Còn nếu mà các bạn muốn làm giỏ hàng
như hàng shopee thì ra nó tách thêm vài
cả nữa cơ
ờ ờ
Em không biết nữa các bạn có để ý thanh
địa chỉ URL như mình hay để ý không
nhưng mình Thứ nhất là mình ghét cái ul
của thầm Google Bởi vì ông mấy ông nhìn
tự nhiên nó ghi cố tình Ghi như này cho
khó ai thể đoán được để mà nhảy sang cái
đường Linh người khác ra ở nhưng mà
chính vì như này nhá nhìn xuống rất khó
chịu
thì các bạn ý kỹ Mày cứ đường link này
mình luôn luôn Để ý kỹ đường Linh này mà
thực và đôi khi mình copy đường link này
Đấy copy duras Nó xảy ra
ở đây Tôi cho ông xem nhé
Anh ta sẽ ra những điều gì
sẽ ra luôn hỏi chấm rồi kèm thêm một cái
loạt bằng sao mày nữa những cái đoạn này
thực là Đoạn này đoạn liên quan đến chi
kinh là điểm kiểm tra xem là bạn bấm
được vào cái đường link này qua cái cái
gì của thằng Facebook ra Tôi rất ghét
phải chịu thêm những cái đoạn thứ nhất
là thêm cái đoạn thấy kinh đoạn led như
thế này led tức cảm chỉ là là kiểu nó nó
là giống như đó kiểu Ai là người
có ai người chia sẻ mấy ông điều này và
và grab này đôi khi nhiều ông biết à hắn
chỉ có thể kiếm tiền nhờ grab này kéo
dạng là cũng truyền ID của ông ngồi đây
xong rồi và hoặc cái đoạn Mã của ông vào
đây Ai bấm vào đường link này có chưa
cái gọi grab mã Zip của ông thì ông sẽ
được phần trăm mà cái gì đó nên tôi rất
khó chịu về Minecraft dung này
Ừ thì à Nên là khi mà ai nói chia sẻ
được Linh đừng lên tôi thường anh rút
gọn cái đường link này ngắn nhất có thể
và đương nhớ không có kèm bên Brad với
ông về sau cũng làm quen với việc là
chia sẻ được Linh ở không lên có cái
đằng sau hỏi chấm nếu nó không quan
trọng Tại sao lại dùng từ nếu không quan
trọng bởi vì có nhiều trường hợp là
đương nhiên là trong cái đường Linh nó
nó kèm theo hợp đây là sự bấm vào đây
bấm vào đây nhé
Em bấm vào đây để mở xem phụ thể cái
khamenei đi này thì ok cái này là cái
đoạn comment đi để nhảy đến được cái ID
cái Comment này nhanh khi có cái này
quan trọng con nếu là sử ông chỉ muốn
đến bài đăng thôi Thì nó chỉ cần có một
đoạn này thôi ông ạ
Ý tôi là một người từ từ trước khi học
là trình Thôi để ý rất kỹ về mà kể Thanh
địa chỉ này Tại tại sao nó có thành địa
chỉ như này Vân Vân rồi mấy ông phải làm
quen dần với việc nhìn anh địa chỉ nó
càng dày thì uống càng phải nhìn để xem
mà có vấn đề gì không
rất nhiều ông học công nghệ tin rồi mà
Mấy ông vẫn chủ quan với ông sẵn sàng
bấm mà mọi Linh có ai gửi mày không lấy
link bấm vào
à mà nếu sử sự mấy ông còn liếm giờ sự
đấy mình cái link rút gọn đấy chị mấy
ông có thể giống như tôi này bơ Window
có cái Windows Săn boss rồi mày không sẽ
copy đường link đấy rồi mày ông vào
Windows bóp cho mở bằng Trong Đời Nó
đang cài sẵn cài mái có số ít à đợi ông
mở đường link bằng trong đấy săn bóp mà
ẩn chị ạ là thấy vùng
Ừ Nó là kiểu nó giống em Máy tính mình
cũng có kết nối mạng nó thử nhưng mà
chưa cài đặt một cái gì trong đấy cả
giống máy tính của mình và độc lập
thì các bạn hoàn toàn thể chạy cả virus
trong này được bởi vì các bạn tắt nó đi
nó sẽ nó sẽ xóa nó sẽ xóa hết mọi thứ
lưu trong nó
các bạn không sợ bị hack khổ như trong
này và nó độc lập nên nó không đưa tài
khoản các bạn trong này em các bạn không
sợ bị hack không ạ
Ồ không Tôi không bị ám ảnh cưỡng chế
mức độ đấy nhưng mà Bởi tôi luôn để ý
đường Linh này thôi cứ tò mò thắc mắc
đừng Linh này thôi
ừ ừ
Cho tôi hỏi Ám Ảnh cũng chế đâu vì ngay
trước mặt tôi bà đang bừa vãi và tôi
đương nhiên là bè nhắc bến nó thì thôi
mày khó chịu chứ bình thường cũng kệ nó
đi
a tiếp theo của bộ mảng giỏi phết nhưng
mà tí do tôi thì tôi bởi vì cái này được
Nãy giờ cũng liên quan đến kiến thức mà
đó ngoại thì thôi chữa cái kia thì rất
ngắn thôi Này nhá Ờ
ẩm thực thực ra là nếu mà các bạn vào
vài cái trang vừa nãy như mình có và
thời trang vì đón cả và mình phải tắt
cái tiện ích chặn quảng cáo đi bởi vì
Ừ nó kiểm tra xem mà các bạn có cài tiện
ích chặn quảng cáo không để nó thông báo
ra các bạn mà chắc mở cái tiện ích đấy
thì các bạn sẽ không được vào trang web
anh cái bài toán ở đây thứ nhất đó là
Mà tại sao nó biết được điều đấy thứ hai
là mà tại sao lại có cái ứng dụng có
tiện ích chặn quảng cáo lên
Ừ đúng rồi
ừ ừ
ở đầu tiên thì các bạn có thể các bạn
khá nhiều bạn vẫn còn ganh ghét quảng
cáo cho sẵn rồi vì nó làm phiền nếu cỡ
đó đang xem dở đã nghe rồi đang bay giờ
vân vân tự nhiên hiển thị ở Quảng cáo
hoài cũng quảng cáo tô dù chạy hết Ừ cái
nội dung các bạn đang đọc đấy thì các
bạn nên cài tiện ích chọn màu Cao đúng
không ạ thì chắc nó đi cái thiện cái
ngày bản chất nó là gì nó vào đoạn ra
Suite để mà kiểm tra xem kiểu nói chung
kiểm tra cái gì đó tội không
300 đọc code của nó để hình dung cụ thể
nói lại chặn những cái phân tử nào nhưng
đại khái nó chặn được tương đối khá
nhiều đúng không ạ Các bạn cải thiện ý
các bạn biết được rồi bởi vì có nhiều
ông nghiên cứu rồi mà
A và việc là
để mà biết được là các bạn có mở cái
điện ích phải không để mà thông báo các
bạn một cái lùi Đây là các bạn phải tóc
thích đi thì mới cho truy cập
á Vừa nãy tôi có vài trang web đấy thì
bạn trong xem nhé
à à
anh
không biết có phải chăng nào không
à à
anh vào quảng cáo hiện lên ra xem ảnh
mình phải đi tìm quảng cáo hay chưa
Ừ nó ra Swift Lên kế sản ở trang loại
loa được xong thì nó mới nhìn thì ra
con trai không ạ
cho các đôi
anh chạy 0201
3 nốt nốt cái cuối
Có ai nhận không nói rồi nó nhạc
Nhưng mà mình nhớ là có hai cái FPT Play
anh không khóc không có có 2
You are the world mình nhớ link link
never die II
à à
ở
đây đây Đà Lạt
ờ ờ
3000 Tôi không phải tìm cái trang phim
có quảng cáo mà Trang có nợ sweep để mà
biết được
thì các bạn mở cái tiện ích chặn quảng
cáo
Ừ thì hồi trước có tương đương nhiên ạ
thứ ba cái loạn xít này làm đơn giản
thôi Chỉ cần kiểm tra xem là cái cái cái
đít đây nó có được hiển thị bên này
không Nếu Deep quảng cáo lại không hiển
thị lên Chứng tỏ ông đã can thiệp vào
cái đít đấy ông ạ thì thông báo như này
thôi ông ạ ạ
Ừ nhưng mà hồi trước hồi trước hồi trước
còn có cái trò buồn cười cực đó đó là
nhiều trang thì nói nghị cái bóp nội
dung bài viết vẫn đầy đủ ở đằng sau phải
to quá về chẳng qua nó kẹo bôi mờ cái
nội dung bằng sau màn hình bị cái cáp
lên như thế này tôi dùng tiện ích chặn
nó phá thôi chặn luôn cả bom đấy thôi
tôi vẫn xem bài viết như bình thường sau
đó đi bây giờ nó chơi Cơ chế này nó ghi
lại ghi để toàn bộ hát trên bờ giống
kiểu dùng đo Kamen Rider cái ghi để lại
hết toàn bộ hoạt mà lâu thì hiển thị ra
nội dung kiểu như này thì chả là mình sẽ
không xoay cái bao kia được không ạ mình
một là mình sẽ phải khi đoạn Script để
mà chặn luôn cả đọx này hay là mình thôi
đành chấp nhận mà thôi tôn trọng người
ra bắt cái chạm vào cá đi đấy Cho hỏi có
mấy ông như thì thế cái bài toán Vừa rồi
tôi nói là dùng đoạn trục vít để vặn
sleep hay dùng đoạn Script để mà biết
được tiện ích Còn đang mở hay không thì
đó Chính à chính là cốt đơ đang tự ăn tự
đấu với cái thằng kia xem não thằng nào
to hơn để kiểm tra có thể sử đúng không
ạ
à mà tương tự giống như cái checkpoint
cũng thế mày chết boss ở bên Facebook
Ừ nó cũng là phổ biến Nhiều nhưng mà
thấy cái là chị coi nó còn rất là rộng ở
trong rất nhiều trang nữa thì ta vẫn là
trẻ hac cu đơ
Tôi kể người lập trình nhóm ạ người ta
Chỗ cố kiểm soát mấy thằng hack cái thứ
là mấy thằng khách thì nó sẽ kiểu
thì nó sẽ đôi khi nó sẽ cốt để mà cố
Lách qua mấy thằng ngày không ạ
bài hát thử thôi hết thời gian rồi cao
tội không từ ra Tôi rất ghét ra Speed
tôi biết là sweep tương đối rồi nhà cũng
ghét nó Tôi thích TP hơn
nghe có ông hôm trước hỏi câu này
em làm gì khi người xung quanh giỏi quá
À thì ra là nếu mà giờ sử xung quanh của
ông Toàn thiên tai thì đương nhiên là
ông cảm thấy ông bị lu mờ hoàn toàn màu
cảm thấy à Ở ngoài
mục đích sống của mình làm gì để mà bọn
nó bưu dài quá vậy nhưng mà như ở mình
hôm trước mình có nói đó là các bạn nhận
được nhận định được các bạn đang thiếu
sót ở đâu để mà phấn đấu thì để bữa đầu
tiên rồi
Ừ nhưng mà
việc cả các bạn muốn phấn đấu hay không
Bởi vì thấy à nó xung quanh giỏi quá rồi
mình không thể bao giờ đuổi kịp bọn họ
giờ các bạn không nên nghĩ tiêu cực đến
nỗi thế
mà các bạn ạ không nên so sánh mình như
thế luôn là sử nhá Tôi bây giờ tôi làm
việc với anh em yêu tim này
Anh Tuấn Anh em rất là rồi
Ừ tôi còn đi ở kiểu sẽ rất là bé nhỏ so
với công ty đấy nhưng mà không Tôi thể
hiện thôi biện à tôi biết điểm mạnh của
tôi là gì Và tôi vẫn đang nổi trội tôi
tôi khẳng định tự vẫn đang hỗ trợ trong
công ty vừa ý là thứ nhất là anh em
trong tim không giỏi biến đôi Trinh mình
giỏi được cái đấy vì mình lắm mồm hơn họ
ít nói ấy và
tiếp theo là mình mình giỏi về tiểu việc
đa-zi-năng mình nghỉ sang được nhiều bên
đúng không Đấy Nghĩa làm gì ở mình sẽ
tận dụng những cái mình mà mình nghĩ là
mình giỏi và nó là ưu điểm và mình thích
điều đấy Đúng là không Dạ Mình thích
điều đấy mình áp dụng vậy thôi Tôi có 10
So sánh những việc là tôi cốt giỏi hơn
anh Tuấn hai cái gì gì đó
a a a
Cho tôi hỏi ở tôi có kém hơn anh Tuấn
cho người yêu thứ Tôi chưa nghĩ những
cái điều đấy ai giỏi hơn thì mình sẽ hỏi
là hợ người ta cũng mình lại càng có
thêm nhiều người để mình hỏi xung quanh
Hồi trước tôi ở trong lớp của tôi
Cái này không phải tức kia gì cả nhưng
mà ở trong nước của tôi hồi đại học đấy
tôi gần như thẳng một trong những hằng
giỏi nhất chỉ vì chỉ vì mấy người kia
còn chưa từng động và máy tính bởi vì kể
cần trường tôi Hồi đấy tôi nói trường
tôi hồi nãy hồi nãy con chẳng nổi được
như bây giờ rồi đấy mới còn mới có ngành
lập trình
nên nhấn mạnh đăng ký vào thứ nhất là
những bạn đấy chưa biết nữa
chế độ trượt tất cả trường thì vào đây
và thừa là à
áo kiểu và theo phong trào Thế nên thành
ra là chẳng biết tí gì về máy tính cũng
bảo hành ra là tôi tôi vào lúc đấy à tôi
nổi hơn mấy mấy ghê hoàn toàn mấy người
kia còn chẳng biết bật máy lúc đầu như
nào thì tự nhiên mình khá hơn của mình
đã ngồi chơi game ngay từ bé tí rồi đấy
Thằng hạn
ở ngân hàng ra là phổi đấy tôi còn tự
kiêu như kiểu là
Ừ mình lập trình chế này quá giỏi rồi
ngày các kiểu thứ cho đến khi biết để
beauty Mình cảm thấy mình chả là cái gì
cả mà mình chẳng biết cái gì cơ
Cho nên lúc đấy tôi mày mới bắt đầu học
họ thêm nhiều hơn còn thời mà tôi ở trên
lớp ấy tôi Còn chán học ngành lập trình
bởi vì tôi nghĩ à Mấy cái này qua dễ mà
mình phải dùng từ rễ Và nó có chảy quá
trám rồi tôi vào đồ ăn 1 của tôi làm
trong phép bán hàng mà tôi không nghĩ
cho tương lai đôi sẽ làm cho web bán
hàng ngay chỉ quanh quẩn mũ cái trang
bán hàng thì làm làm gì đấy thế này nha
tối Hồi đấy chứ chán lắm trình cục nhưng
mà chính vì khi mà gặp được những cái
anh ra giỏi kia bài nhảy áp dụng rất
nhiều công nghệ làm rất nhiều thứ làm
tôn Cá thứ thì thôi Mình cảm thấy cậu
mới có mục đích để nó học cái ngành lập
trình này
cho nên à
đi cấy cấy hướng cái tóc nhìn của mấy
ông ấy quan trọng này là
Ừ nếu phải nhìn theo hướng nào không
phải lạc quan quá không phải Bi con quá
thực tế quá vẫn vân vân Tôi không biết
Ừ nhưng mà chắc sản là mấy ông phải nhìn
theo những theo một cách nào đó để mà
sao cho có lợi cho bản thân mình chưa
cuộc đời mình mà bọn mình cứ bi quan hay
mình cứ kiểu tự ti thì
thế cho nó không hay ở ông ạ
anh không ai giúp được mình rồi đấy cả
nóng lạnh
à à
Ừ đúng rồi Nếu mà giỏi hơn tất cả những
người xung quanh như kiểu bị Tự tin quá
ra ấy nếu ông hỏi từ đâu và mấy ông cũng
kiểu
ở chỗ Thực ra thì tôi
tôi kể mấy ông người vụ là là theo là
thử hỏi Hỏi Nhanh nhỉ
theo mấy ông đó là khi mà đi du ý thì
top mấy Top mấy là à Nói chung là đạt
giải giải nhất giải nhì giải ba giải
khuyến khích
à hay là tư đi Chẳng hạn theo mấy ông
áo vải nào sẽ sẽ khiến con người ta phải
phấn đấu nhiều hơn
U13 sẽ
khi người ta sẽ cậu sẽ phải phấn đấu
nhưng phải biết phấn đấu nhiều hơn nữa
khi họ sẽ cố gắng hơn nữa
Ừ đúng rồi bạn kia nói Rảnh nhỉ cay nhất
là chọn giải giải nhì không bao giờ phấn
đấu nhiều hơn
Ừ đúng rồi chạy 3 màu phấn đấu nhiều
Đúng rồi đấy các bạn hiểu hiểu ý mình ơi
ờ ờ giải 42 giải khuyến khích họ sẽ bị
nản Họ không ở phần đầu nữa đâu vì họ bị
cách xa quá nhiều rồi dạy nhi họ sẽ luôn
cay hơn cái nhất luôn nó sẽ luôn nghĩ
rằng à Người ta thiếu một tí bằng nhất
rồi nó sẽ cay chứ nó không tập trung và
phấn đấu con giải ba thì nó sẽ luôn có
cái có cảnh khoảng cách đủ để mà họ thấy
là họ còn thiếu nhiều nhưng mà họ không
đến nỗi là biến iPad nghĩa họ không mức
đến anh thu của hoàn toàn họ sẽ phấn đấu
nhiều nhất từ trước hay tôi luôn thích
số 3 bởi vì thế
ẩm thực Hà là từ cấp 1 cho đến nữa đại
học tôi toàn vào lớp
a303 gió vào lớp c ngờ từ trước ngày tôi
luôn Thứ ba lớp
tớ thích số 3A
chỉ số hạnh và và trong trường hợp và
vợ chồng trong trường hợp mà rảnh và các
bạn nãy giờ chẳng ai nói giải nhất để
phấn đấu nhiều lắm họ Đôi khi họ đứng ở
trên đỉnh vinh quang rồi họ lại tự kia
và họ lại càng
thì họ lại càng dầu ở dễ mắc nhiều sai
lầm để mà tụt tụt sâu không phanh nhiều
nhất không ạ nên thành ra là
các bạn không bao giờ nên kiểu kỳ vọng
mình được 10 điểm hay là kiểu
dài nhất một cái gì đó
à còn trên thang điểm 10 nữa cơ trên
thang điểm mười mấy ông biết điểm nào ở
điểm ổn nhất để phải phấn đấu hơn không
à à
ý
kiến hay điểm mười cái điểm nào sẽ khiến
mấy ông cảm thấy phải phấn đấu hơn nữa
Giống cái dại 3 vừa rồi
Anh ở điểm nào lý tưởng
A gọi bạn chưa trả lời một phát đồng
luôn kìa nó số 7
Ừ nó
tôi quên không nói phê vậy nha
37 hồi điểm 8 là được cho là điểm loại
giỏi rồi Nhiều người an thật là cái điểm
đấy hồi nó điểm an toàn của bên gọi
khi con điểm bậy nó là điểm mà cắt
ngưỡng giỏi nhiều âm sẽ cố phấn đấu tiền
mặt để mà vượt hơn chữ điểm 7 hóa trị
mức khá
a 9,5 Nhìn mấy ông thứ mấy Cai rồi mà
Mấy ông sẽ phấn đấu có giống như cái gì
Vừa rồi tôi nói
ô tô quên nói phê phẩy đấy ạ
anh kể cho con gái chuyện gì à Nếu không
vừa à Mấy ông ông áp dụng cái câu mà tôi
vừa hỏi để bạn ấy trả lời cũng được của
ông nêu quan điểm như tôi nói với bạn ấy
sẽ nghĩ là ông một là ông là một thằng
triết lý sàn hay là hay là ông và một
hàng nhà suy nghĩ rất là sâu xa có nhìn
đời bằng cái ánh nhìn xa xăm ấy kiểu thế
thơ Ngồi tu thêm cốc cà phê đen không
đường nữa Quá chuẩn luôn ấy thì thì em
đấy sẽ ngoài việc ngưỡng mộ ông thì sẽ
nghĩ là bởi có quá nhiều thứ mà mình cần
phải học hỏi và chưa biết về anh này
nhưng thành con gái thì ra con đợi có
một cái sự tò mò gì đó chị sẽ bị cuốn
hút bởi
anh bởi sự tò mò đấy sẽ mua tìm hiểu ông
hơn thì chắc chắn sẽ còn những buổi đi
chơi tiếp theo
Em hãy chia sẻ Thật
Ừ Đấy lý do mà nhiều ông mà kiểu tán con
gái 350 độ một cái thằng mà kiểu một
tuần mới quen tự nhiên đổ của kia thằng
kia nó có quá nhiều thứ hoặc đứa này
không biết nên được ấy sẵn sàng chấp
nhận cái lời tỏ tình hơn một thằng một
mình ở biết rõ từ đầu đến cuối rồi
à à
a tiếp theo nha à
a cuốn hút bởi người thông minh cũng
không ở đúng đâu nhé
anh Bởi vì thực ra nhiều người phải cuốn
hút bởi sự hài hước ở cuốn hút bởi sự
lạnh lùng Trẻ Trâu nó Vân ngõ Nhiều cá
nhưng mà chủ yếu à cuốn hút bởi sự tò mò
khẳng định vẫn là tò mò đó như thế Con
gái có gì đó hiểu dễ bị
anh đương với lại thằng kia cũng phải
thể hiện mình gọi là cũng phải hợp một
tí chư Giả sử là các bạn khoe với các
dòng Cốt nó chẳng tò mò thì mình cái cốt
cùng với ông đâu chả nặng thế
khi họ mấy ông khoe nhân phẩm cốt nhân
phẩm game của mấy ông lý nào là sự mấy
bài không đam mê về game đấy các bạn
sàng quan tâm
Ừ nhưng mà Nếu giả sử ông lại một trong
những cái game phục đỉnh cao ở trong
game đấy cho dù bạn không biết cái game
này những bạn ấy lại thích thì cái đấy
lại liên quan đến công việc là cái tính
sở hữu hôm trước là tôi có nói
em ngồi trà đá nói chuyện riêng chị ạ
Ông rủ gái đi trà đá là
số 1 là mấy em bây giờ khó tán như cậu
Đấy thế là tùy đấy nếu anh ấy em sống ảo
chứ khó 8 cái cái đấy con mấy em à Cậu
đã rủ được đi xa đái thì ông lại nói
chuyện không phải vì chính chị đâu Ông
nói chuyện này đủ thứ nói chuyện với cả
18 + hay là cái gì cho cũng được rồi mẹ
em bé có cá tính rồi lúc em mấy em điều
đấy mẹ em ấy chơi với bọn trai như bình
thường ấy thế được
nói cái chủ đề gì cũng được như bạn bè
với nhau thôi
Em đừng có để cập liên tục 18 + mở được
nhưng ám trẻ kéo
khi mà ông dụ để con cái đi ăn cơm bình
dân và uống trà đá thì
số 1 là ông mà bạn kiểu dạng mà
cô bạn thân hay biểu
Ừ nó nó có tình cảm với ông rồi thì ông
nói ông bất kỳ cái hoa quả hoặc cả ba nó
nó kiểu dạng là nó quen thì sẽ ra con
trai rồi lên thành cái gì cũng được nó
nói chung một cái tính cách rồi
à à
Ê mấy ông đừng có rủ con gái đi trà sữa
hay là cà phê tướng nhưng mà không muốn
nói chuyện đúng không mấy ông cách để và
đường
vào tim con gái nhanh thì cả tin con
trai nữa đó đường dạ dày tự từng nói rồi
Rủ đi ăn đấy rồi đi ăn sau đó đi mấy ông
muốn làm gì sau thì làm
một làm gì sau đây làm được nhiều thứ
lắm Cứ ra sửa máy ông rủ đi uống nước Ăn
trắng miệng Xem phim Vân nhưng vẫn ở đi
lần đầu tiên đã quan trọng vì có phải
chọn quán ngon nhé chứ không phải giống
như tôi vừa nói là chọn còn minh dân rồi
nhé I
Em gửi đi nhậu Đấy ông ông rủ đi nhậu
cũng được nhưng mà thơ ca là với nhiều
bạn con gái không thích nhậu vào các nó
không chưa đủ tin tưởng ông để nhậu vân
vân ông người lạ nó sao mà dám nhậu cùng
không để ông nhậu nó
ừ ừ
khi lần đầu rủ đi ăn kìa
a tinh tinh ông bây giờ ông chỉ cần đả
kẹo bà đã kiểu anh mới biết quán này ổi
có thứ chẳng sao cả à
em ngồi bình dân thì đúng là dễ nói
chuyện hơn nhưng mà không phải bạn gái
nào cũng thích cái điều đấy
a football
cũng đúng nhớ thời ca Chính vì cái
football đấy thì bạn đấy sẽ nhớ ông hơn
anh hơn ông mà dẫn được bạn này lên quá
ngon bạn đấy sẽ còn nhớ ông hơn cả việc
có một hàng khác dù bạn đấy đến quán
sang chảnh nhưng mà không ngon
Ừ ông mà rủ mày đi ăn bún đậu họ đi ăn
giả cầy và con kia kìa bạn có tính cách
thì bạn ấy sẽ thích bạn sẽ thấy hộp cu
luôn Nhưng mà như tôi nói đôi khi nó sẽ
đi vào vết xe thành bạn thân nên là tôi
Không khuyên được khoảng đấy lắm
à à Thôi lại tập trung là tại ngồi trả
lời Lemon rồi
nhất là hôm trước có phải tôi khuyên Nếu
mà vẫn nên đọc cái lỗi và một khi cái
mai que i5 dâu 21 mayahuel iklan hoặc
fax mà bảo lỗi thì tớ làm chị câu truy
vấn của ông về vấn đề mà ông phải nhớ
nhớ đọc lỗi vào máy ông sẽ phải đai câu
truy vấn ạ kiểm tra
a tiếp theo ở
nhà mình có ghi lại cái này ngồi chắc là
đền bù sau mình trả lời đi chị 2k em
mình buổi sau trả lời nhé bởi vì em mình
thấy hôm nay được hơi lan man quá mình
sẽ có bơ mình sẽ chữa bài Nốt này trước
thì trả lời đúng câu hỏi gì nữa
Hôm nay mình sẽ cấu hình cơ sở liệu
thì tại sao phải phải nói cấu hình cơ sở
dữ liệu về hôm trước là mình mới chị dạy
các bạn với vụ gửi mail nhưng mà
anh tò mò thì để bữa sau trả lời có thêm
mấy thứ ông to mo Tiếc à
à Hôm trước mình dạy các bạn với vụ gửi
mail nên sự Ca là cái đấy nó hơi bị sai
so với nhiều bên anh mà Thậm chí cả đến
tôi đang làm nữa Tại sao gọi cũng phải
nói là sai cho ông xem
ở đó là mình không hề lưu lại trong B
database về việc là
bạn bạn đấy có chấp nhận việc gửi males
Star thông báo quảng cáo hay không các
bạn biết vụ để không ạ
Các bạn khi đăng ký khi nó đăng ký mưa
gì đó nó luôn có là bạn có muốn nhận
thông báo các thứ thứ quảng cáo bên tôi
không Đương nhiên là mấy ông đôi khi ở
thật cả đời đi hoặc các bạn lỡ Click vào
thì đọc nhầm nó thành các bạn đồng ý đến
điều khoản sử dụng hay không còn thức
các bạn chẳng bờ đọc nốt Nên các bạn cứ
thích hết là những thứ có thể rồi Các
bạn đăng ký thì thì cái việc đó chúng
vào khi các bạn chấp nhận điều đấy thì
các bạn định hoặc không chấp nhận được
lời nữa thì các bạn cũng phải lưu lại
một rồi các bạn lưu lại một cột trong
trong bạn ví dụ bạn khách hàng lưu lại
cột là cột ạ kiểu oa em thừa cột mày chỉ
có 2 giá trị thôi Nó kiểu có mà không mà
nó không ạ
cột này có thể đặt tên nó là kiểu
ví
dụ tao tên của Cô Tô kiểu nhái được ví
dụ can spam thì email
em chẳng hạn hoa cà can't Send email
marketing được hả Nếu mà tên nó dài
nhưng mà nó dễ hiểu sẽ như thế này đấy
các bạn được
mấy kiểu như nó sẽ buôn lần nữa cả chua
Phone đúng không ạ Đấy thì nó sẽ hợp lý
hơn và khi mà gửi mail các bạn sẽ phải
lấy tất cả những khách hàng mà có kiểu
nó là Chu thì mới gửi chứ không hề là
một kiểu các bạn cứ gửi stimer tất cả
tất cả khách hàng được sẽ không không
thích điều đấy Đặt tên là sắp qua được
đúng rồi đặt tên Sprite nó hợp lý hơn
thì theo dõi không ạ Đấy thì
Thì đấy là việc cấu hình cơ sở liệu cho
vụ gửi mail liên quan đến việc thông báo
một cái gì đó nhưng mà giả sử là các bạn
thấy có một vài Trang nó còn thông báo
nó còn cài đặt thông báo nhiều hơn chứ
hỏi về mỗi quảng cáo và xử nhá Anh cũng
Media mình nhớ medium có nhưng có nhiều
trang các thứ nữa nhưng mà nhấm mail mà
vì thằng này nó có cấu hình thông báo
Tương thứ khá là chi tiết
ô hay nhưng phải mở BN vậy đâu vẫn đang
lên này
lên hơi chậm
Thế còn trang nào mà ở
cơ cấu hình nữa nhỉ Thằng Facebook ra có
đấy thằng Facebook mà có như nó không có
cấu hình cụ thể cụ thể là cái gì được
phép thông báo có gì không thì như thế
này xem lại hỏng Facebook bác mấy ông
Thực ra mấy ông cũng ít để vụ là ấn vào
cài đặt để mà
em
tìm ở kiểu Xem lướt qua tất cả nó có gì
đúng không Không nên quen dần việc là
kiểu luôn ấn vào đấy xem đi
ở đây này có có có Này đây ví dụ bạn
muốn cái này có gửi mail ơi không Này
bạn muốn có cái này có gửi mail hay
không này chẳng hạn với Vân này Đây đúng
ạ thì thì cái cài đặt này này thì các
bạn thấy là toàn bộ Cái này la nào giống
như cái sản phẩm và cấu hình sản phẩm
của tôi đó mấy ông phải tách nó hẳn
riêng ra 1 bảng nữa
ở bảng liên quan đến và cấu hình tương
tự thế và Đây là kiểu nọ mình mình chỉ
cần lần này mình sẽ cần lưu lại việc là
khách hàng có đồng ý không nên không còn
lưu em có giá trị á sửa đây mình sẽ có
cột khách hàng à Bạn thấy hàng này
Đấy và bạn là bạn dụ cấu hình cũng được
có thể gộp chung tên tên kiểu nhẹ được
cấu hình thôi hoặc cấu hình mail
có email đi chọn kiểu tên khác đi không
ạ sau đó thì đây sẽ là dụ cấu hình email
khách hàng luôn vẫn
anh không ạ ạ
ừ ừ
một
số người khách hàng mà kiểu cứ mỗi lần
tích vào đây lưu lại thì em chỉ là mình
sẽ lưu lại thêm một cái cấu hình email
vào trong này không ạ Còn nếu mà khách
hàng mà bỏ cái tích đi thì các bạn xoạc
à mình mình thường em làm cơ chế kiểu
này nhé á xe khách hàng kích thích Xong
hết rồi ấn ấn nút được rồi nhé và có
nhiều mình sẽ xóa hết toàn bộ những cái
cấu hình email cũ của khách hàng này đi
Sau đó thì in rớt một vạt lại thì nó sẽ
luôn ổn các bạn không phải kiểm tra việc
là khách hàng đã bỏ thích cái gì hay đã
thích thêm mới cái gì quản Chỉ đơn giản
xóa hết đi rồi xóa lại cùng một lúc thì
ra sao đấy
chị Thu hồi các bạn sẽ thắc mắc là thế
còn cái vụ gửi mail khi ẩn quên mật khẩu
thì sao anh không ạ
Em gửi mail khi ẩn quên mật khẩu nó sẽ
nó sẽ khác với cái vụ cấu hình này
Ừ nó cũng giống ở điểm là khách hàng
phải có yêu cầu thì mới gửi mail nhưng
nó khác thời điểm là nó không Thứ nhất
là nó không lưu lại trong bảng khách
hàng và thường thường nhé và nó sẽ làm
cái kiểu như thế này dễ thương làm kiểu
ngày
chị đã sửa là nếu đặt tên tiếng Anh thì
sẽ là tên là phó forgot password còn tên
tiếng Việt được cho là quên mật khẩu đi
tên tiếng Anh nghe Văn Bộ có vẻ hay hơn
đấy thì thì nó sẽ thường hay kiểu nhà
nhé
thì nó sẽ cột làm mã khách Hà ờ
a Token à
ở đầu tiên trước mắt là như thế này đã
thôi Chẳng biết ok này nên dịch tiếng
Việt nó gì mã
gọi mãi ngày hơi thu quá cứ để nó tặng
các em nhé
đầu tiên ấy là khi mà dạo sự vào khách
hàng AA Quyên khách hàng
có mã là một quên mật khẩu thì nó sẽ ấn
vào quên mật khẩu thì bản chất là họ sẽ
gửi email về cho thằng khách hàng này
đúng ạ
email của bạn ơi sự abc@gmail.com sẽ gửi
cho bạn lại cái gì thường sẽ cái đường
link để khi bấm vào đường link đấy thì
sẽ nhập mật khẩu mới để mà truy cập và
bình thường đúng không ạ Cái cái cái vụ
đấy thứ nhất là khi khách hàng bấm quên
mật khẩu thì nó sẽ lưu lại và xong bảo
quên mật khẩu cái mã khách hàng một này
và có một cái tô canxi ngang ngẫu nhiên
ngay lập tức để mà khách hàng bấm vào
cái đường Linh quên mật khẩu ra sửa à
trang web của các anh
như này sau đó chị có thể là for Lost
password chẳng hạn
password đ.tp school.do kem bằng chính
là cái đoạn đoạn này
ạ sau khi enter vào thì bạn chất là các
bạn Nhập mật khẩu mới cho cái thằng
khách hàng có cái Token này thì nó sẽ
nối ra và nhập lại mật khẩu mới cho cái
thằng khách hàng còn mãi là 1 như thế
này đông ạ Thế nên là gì đấy Ở lý do mà
các ô tô cái cái bà này nên tách riêng
khỏi cái bảng khách hàng tại sao Vì
không phải ai cũng cần
cách reset mật khẩu như thế nóng lạnh
không phải ai cần đến xem mật khẩu giờ
sử có bạn bảo tống cái cô Token vào đây
để đỡ phải thêm một bảng mới nếu mà như
này cái này ra là thứ nhất là cột này bị
chấm một là nó bị trống cả hai lần khi
mà tạo thêm mới khách hàng thì cái cột
này Chồng rất nhiều đúng ạ bởi vì ai
quên mật khẩu đâu chẳng ai quên cả cái
thứ nhất thứ hai là nếu mà giờ sử các
bạn lưu lại cái to Ken bà như thế này
khi nó cố định nó đang cố định
em ạ cố định ngày tớ đảm chỉ là nếu giờ
sự có 1 2 hack ở đó nó ngồi như vừa rồi
Mình bảo là nó gõ đường link này nó thử
to scan bằng một to cao bằng hai to Kem
nó sẽ chạy để khi a ra đồng to nhân ngẫu
nhiên là nó tự nhiên lại lại vào được
tất làm chị ạ Có cái Linh nghệ tồn tại
nó sẽ hoàn toàn thay đổi mật khẩu các
bạn chọn nên là thứ nhất là vứt cái to
scan sang một bảng cái thứ hai là
thì nó sẽ có thêm một cột nữa là cô thôi
à
cách tạo bởi lúc nào hoặc ạ thời gian
hiệu lực đến bao giờ vân vân vân thường
mà tạo bởi lúc nào
gọi là thời gian tạo đi ừ
ở dưới ở sữa là ngày hôm nay ở cạn bảo
là
về giá control ăn xuống gì căn tài để
lấy được ngày hôm nay à
ở đây đôi khi điện theo dầu luôn một cái
nó 24 giờ thường hay các bạn thế đường
link để mà làm kích hoạt hay là một cái
gì đó thường ai chị sóng vọng thì được
hai tư giờ thôi để tránh việc là thằng
hạ thái cơ Nói thể giả được bởi vì sao
Bởi vì à thường lại bảng này sẽ đưa 1
con boss xóa cứ hay nó cứ một phút nó
lại chạy một lần họ 5 phút chạy một lần
để kiểm tra cho em ạ cái link này nó đủ
24 giờ chưa đủ rồi thì nó sẽ xóa toàn bộ
những cái đủ 24 giờ đi để tránh việc
hacker có thể mò ra được cái đường link
đấy để mà hack
Ừ đúng rồi đổi xong mật khẩu thì cũng
xóa cái này hoặc chưa đổi thì trong vòng
24 giờ Cái này cũng sẽ bị xóa
thì nó sẽ có 1 con boss nó chạy luôn xóa
băng xóa Đông ạ Đấy Và thậm chí là thế
là hồi trước ở công ty tôi nữa không
phải chơi em cho ai nữa đó là
nếu mà các bạn làm như thế này thì cứ
nhớ là cột mà khách hàng
a mã khách hàng này các bạn đang để nó
là khóa chính đúng ạ Nó duy nhất Anh
thành ra là nếu Giả sử một khách hàng mà
bấm quên mật khẩu thêm một phát nữa
cô ta xử nó bấm quên mật khẩu nhé bấm
lên phát nữa chỉ ông nghe cái tao cái
này nó sẽ phải vụ nên là vô hiệu và nó
sẽ ghi đè lên bụng một cái tóc em mới
như ngày đông ạ Nhưng nếu giả sửa Hằng
khách hàng nó Star ấn quên mật khẩu ảnh
chụp phát thì các bạn không phải gửi
chụp cái mail cho một khách hàng được
thứ nhất là con server các bạn sẽ sẽ dễ
bị cho là spam thứ hai là gửi mail nó nó
phí đấy mày ông ạ Nó mất phí đấy em
thành ra mà rất nhiều tranh này Nó sẽ có
giới hạn việc làm một ngày mày chỉ được
phép quên 23 lần thôi nó không nói
chuyện được
Ừ nó nó không có chuyện đó kiểu cho các
bạn spam kiểu quên mật khẩu chục lần một
ngày đâu thế nó sẽ thường này vẫn để
thêm một cột nữa là cột mã tự động tăng
chẳng hạn
khoa học một số lần ở trong này nhờ kiểu
gì miệng phải đếm lại xem à với một
khách hàng ký ngày hôm nay nó đã tạo bao
nhiêu lần gửi mệt Quên mật khẩu rồi đấy
tôi cho ký ức là một hành khách hàng chỉ
được quên một lần nhiều trang này nó khó
tính hơn là kiểu nó kiểm tra là a mã
khách hàng ở trong bảng này tồn tại rồi
thế cảm chị là lỡ ẩn quên mật khẩu trong
ngày hôm nay rồi nó không cho nó không
gửi thêm nữa thằng Facebook bây giờ nó
hình như chơi cờ chị đấy vậy nó Nó là
kiểu nó không gửi không gửi
mail hay ở không khối tin nhắn cho nữa
Mày tự đi mới giải quyết sau 24 giờ nữa
thì mày mới được bật lên phát nữa
xe tải mã số 3 cơ chế của bọn nó sẽ làm
như thế này
cho con bú gửi mail để mà
Ừ nếu muốn tôi cốt luôn bọn em hay thôi
nghỉ cốt luôn hai thôi
Ừ thôi cứ cốt nha
Anh tên là Focus
a password này ạ
à à
anh đi xe 3 cục ngoại
à mình làm như kiểu cơ chế đơn giản thôi
Mình cứ làm cái cơ chế là kiểu một người
dùng chỉ có được quên mật khẩu một lần
cho mỗi ngày bạn sẽ là Custom led
à à
Tik Tok em à
à À thế thật à
Ừ cái để Hamster được họ biết tụi mình
mình như mình từng nói thì các bạn nên
dùng timestamp để mà nó nó là số dây các
bạn quy ước lại về thời gian nào cũng
được giờ phút giây hoàng ngày tháng năm
tuổi
những kẻ và cha này 200 nhân rất thoải
mái
thocan được rất dài tại đi ok
bài hát tự nhiên là mình lên kết nối
liên kết quả ngoại đến bạn của Summer
nữa thôi tạm kệ đi bây giờ sự à Bây giờ
mình sẽ có cái đen sai
sai lúc nghỉ à
ô chai này mình mình sẽ có nút là quên
mật khẩu thẻ a này nhảy sang cái Trang à
à forgot
password
trên pp này à
ở
đây này à
à à
ở đây bấm ở đây sẽ nhảy sang cái file
này đóng lại phải bạn chất là các bạn
thường hay thấy là nhập email đó ngoại
nhập email sau mỗi sẽ luôn thông báo cái
chung chung là tôi sẽ gửi cho bạn Kính
thưa nó có những điểm giả sử với mấy lần
thôi tôi còn chẳng nhớ rồi đã đăng ký ở
đây chưa Nhưng mà nó luôn bà gửi được
email Anh không biết nữa nếu mà Đấy ra
cũng thông cảm nó thôi Nếu là sự nó
thông báo là email này không tồn tại
thật là nhiều loại cơ sẽ hack đường vụ
đấy Kệ nó sẽ luôn kiểm tra Email tồn tại
email không
có vài trang này nó vẫn thông báo đây
email không tồn tại trong cơ sở liệu nó
có đấy à
Em gửi mail
đổi mật khẩu
hai mã truyền hình Trái Ngược full set
of Ghost bản Word
tên này
mệt hết
12 giờ rồi Bây giờ tôi sẽ nhập email của
một cái khách hàng đơn như vậy một khách
hàng hợp lệ không ạ tại ra xử như hai
luôn cái ấn vào thì nó sẽ nhảy đến cái
file này
anh
phải chở xử lý thôi anh thì mình sẽ lấy
email về
sau đó thì mình sẽ kết nối cơ sở dữ liệu
không ạ
ngồi mình sẽ lấy
search
Ờ ID from customer
Where email bằng
lại email này
ai thèm đi mi một cũng được nhưng thật
ra lại email các bạn để uống nick rồi
không phải lo vụ này sau đó đi à
và kết quả
là lấy thằng đầu tiên này à
à à
ở Hà Nội đầu tiên ông ấy kiểm tra xem nó
có chắc chắn là đúng đúng Chỉ có một cái
quả không không Đã họ sửa nó bằng bằng
một cái lắm chị ạ chỉ có một cái quay
trở về nó đúng thì các bạn mới có vụ gửi
mail đúng ạ Bạn nhớ phimae hôm trước
không ạ
thì mình sẽ chạy đến file này 3A
vì
sao mình sẽ gọi đến cái Hàn mail
I think you're a
ở Arsenal để chuyển lên mà kê thì mình
sẽ có lên đấy lấy ID để mà để mình sẽ
lưu lại vào trong bảng à forget password
forgot password nữa
Chờ Đợi tí nhé Để Thế thì bình tĩnh đã
khi mà bằng một ngày rồi thì mình sẽ
phải in such a đâu không phải in sớm à
Đợi tí
làm phải làm nhiều cái
ở bảng for password tôi phải để cái này
là khóa chính đã để tránh việc là một
khách hàng
tại nhiều lần
Ừ anh Hải à
anh Bởi vì một khách hàng tại quận 2
đường link bấm vào 2 link đều được thì
nó lại say quá nó sẽ chỉ theo đường lên
cuối thôi đầu tiên là mình lại phải kiểm
tra lại câu espa Shake
cao ca với nó sẽ nhanh hơn
forma forgot
password à
Anh
quay của Summer ID bằng cái đi dù người
dùng không ạ ID người dùng sẽ bằng
Michael Faraday này
He has issued này
tại cột ID này
Nệm để à
em bận gì
anh đợi tôi một tí
à à
Ừ thôi tôi sẽ làm ở chỗ này đi Thấy
thằng đầu tiên này ai đi sẽ bằng ích tại
cột ID này mà nên sẽ thế
nên để tí mình gửi mail mình có tên mà
Ừ anh sẽ ai đi đúng ạ
à à
em ngồi kiểu này dễ bị SN sân nhưng tôi
không Trước tôi nói rồi Tôi đang dạy các
bạn Tôi chỉ nói qua mấy ông kiểu về hiểu
hiểu tư duy cốc thôi còn để mà phòng
tránh nó được ra đến đồ án 2 thì nó có
thư viện hỗ trợ các bạn đi khám tráng
rồi còn không thì hôm trước mình cũng
chỉ một vài hàng để phòng tránh rồi
nhưng bây giờ mình làm nhanh thì làm cốc
kiểu thuần đơn giản thôi
đã đến nước ạ đến này mình lại phải chạy
ngày tiếp
cài đặt tên thật là tôi hơi khó chịu vụ
đặt tên các thứ thứ tránh chung các thứ
à à
ở tại Cao sao này
lấy ra check đi tặng cái gọi là chết đi
đấy nha ít
Hack
bằng bằng A
Đó là tại sao tôi đến nghỉ thì đến cũng
được nhưng mà đến như thế này là để để
tôi tôi tôi
nghĩ là làm đơn giản được không cần phải
mất công đến tôi định đến là để mà kiểm
tra xem là khách hàng này quên mật khẩu
chưa Nếu quên mật khẩu rồi thì sẽ xóa nó
đi và tạo cái mới hoặc lấy lại cái cũ
nhưng tôi nghĩa đơn giản là tôi Xóa sử
đi cho đó tôi luôn in rất cái mới cũng
được nhỉ
à Còn nếu mà Mấy ông muốn làm kiểm tra
giống như trong Facebook giấm tôm vừa
nói để tránh Vietstar email để vào mình
bị mất tiền đấy có nhiều thằng nó chơi
cho cứ Star quên mật khẩu liên tục
10 nhiều sao không kiểm tra vụ đấy kiểm
tra của ông sẽ mất tiền khi mà gửi mail
nó cũng như là bị dễ bị dính mấy thằng
Dịch vụ nó sẽ nó sẽ nghĩ ông Star khách
hàng thì thì
mẹ mày ông sẽ phải ạ phải phải chơi cơ
chế là luôn luôn kiểm tra lại luôn đến
lại đã xem và hàng ngày hôm nay ẩn quên
mật khẩu chưa thấm thía trong 3 ngày gần
đây nó quên mật khẩu không ngờ nhãn cũng
được lên Vân Tứ nhiều cách kiểm tra rồi
đấy Còn nếu bây giờ mới làm cho đơn giản
thì đơn giản Xóa đi luôn Xóa cái cũ đi
sau đó đi à
I Delete này
luôn Xóa cái cũ đi sau đó luôn Lại in
xuất cái mới thế cũng được
em đỡ phải Mất công kiểm tra cũng được
Ừ nó chạy nhà luôn Xóa đi này sau đó
easy cái mới Sao lại sao lại cái to scan
đấy mà nhập luôn bạn có kem thì
thì hôm trước mình nói mình có thể dùng
cái uid cũng được
cho
hàm yuwadee
cho hàm một cái Hàn Thì đó ngẫu nhiên
một đoạn chuỗi không ạ quay đi cũng là
một cái rất là hay nó thường tránh chung
à
à à
mà
hãng sẽ sinh âm một đoạn Chọn ngẫu nhiên
ở đó sau đó mình đi sơ ở trong nhà thì
bê Thôi làm đi shirt into
your Lost password
Alo Nó là
ai đi này
Tik Tok em này
mà thực ra là cái cụt cây cột
Crystal Hết ngày này mà ông về Bphone nó
luôn cũng được
Ừ đúng rồi con không cho nhập mật khẩu
cũ đúng ở phải lưu lại tất cả mật khẩu
cũ ấy
Ừ nhưng mà thường thằng Facebook mà chơi
Nó chỉ lưu lại được 10 lần thôi mình nhớ
Thế nó không thể gọi nhiều đâu nếu thể
cho defoe như này để bé uống đỡ phải
nhập cái cục này cũng được nhé
ở đây sẽ chữa code customer ID và Cu
Token là cao ông Điền và thôi Ở cộng chị
cũng chạy như này nó xong đấy nó đừng
linh của mấy ông mới là quan trọng đường
link của mấy ông sẽ là gì linh của mấy
ông sẽ ra sẽ cần đường link ở trang web
thường là mấy ông sẽ dùng kệ Hàn để mà
lấy được cụ thể kể tên miền đang cho đến
à à
It is apparent that
A gọi phát mà cô đơn à dâu
tờ tất cả quên URL này
à à
ở
đây tôi thử nhé
à à
số
bài viết một cái phong trần thì nếu hệ
thống nhưng trong trên dưới cái gì bất
kỳ đọc được chẳng qua viết khỏe hàm Sau
đó mình gọi Hà Nội thôi
từ ngày tôi thử EXO cái Hà mày ra
ở Nội Bài đây đi hoặc axit ở đây
cho xem
à à
Ừ mai cơ bản tại mấy ông thấy không ra
mình sẽ cầm cái loại này cho mình không
cần đầy đủ cái đoạn sau này thì ở đây là
mình xóa Dạo này đi
AE đăng nhập thử sáng đi nhé ạ
ở đó ok rồi đúng không ạ Mình sẽ chỉ cần
đoạn này thôi
Ừ kệ không cần đâu thế cho mình chỉ cần
đợi này thôi đây sẽ ra hàng để lấy được
cái kiểu Đường Linh Đông ạ sẽ là con
đường link này cho nó sẽ nổi lên cái
file nào đó là sự file đặt tên là file
kiểu
để mà đổi mật khẩu mới mày không ạ sẽ da
Feiya
v-trans yip password hạ
fp hỏi chấm to
bằng số nối tới đoạn Token vào đây đái
đường Linh ở sẽ như thế này die link để
ông xem nhé
bộ
váy alo
à à
anh ở đây à
thì nó sẽ sinh em một đoạn thocan ngẫu
nhiên thứ Uruguay ở đây vẫn nhắn với ông
thích thì kệ dài hơn được
ở nhà tôi nghĩa để lại tương đối rồi Ừ
thì bây giờ ông sẽ sên Milk xe Mio vào
Ừ
cái email kia đóng
Em
email này à
khi nêm này và
ô hay thù thay thôi là mình sẽ đặt một
cái thái Hồ trưa nay là
trên new password ạ ạ
Ừ bà nội dung body-content nó ngoại nội
dung
tên à
Em
bấm vào đây để
khi nhận dài em ạ
Đấy rồi Thế à đây da rất
nhảy đến lần này
hiệu lực trong
24 giây ạ như thế này
khi thành lập tiếp thì đôi khi nó sẽ bậm
mã không ạ Con tên
trạng như này à
em chả được đấy thử Phát
em chặn bắt đầu nhẹ cho được
đi đái giờ mình sẽ
a star
Em bấm vào đây sẽ dẫn đến
ờ ờ
khi
chưa Bấm đây nhờ đến cho cha nó đang đâu
đấy
Có quần Linh này mày có Bình Định lên
được có bị Linh nhá
đó sẽ nhảy lên cái file này
à à
ạ bây giờ mấy ông chỉ cần sửa cái này
thôi sửa cái đầu tiên tạo pha này sau
mấy ông chỉ cần kiểm tra to Kem này có
hợp lệ không có hợp lệ thì mới ông sẽ
cho đổ mật khẩu và mấy ông phải xóa thế
Xóa cái này trong bà này đi không ạ à à
ê alo còn ai đầu tiên mình sẽ kiểm tra
sự cân bằng flash ok
sao lại kết nối Ngoại
còn nói chuẩn p&i
đ.tk đoạn nào nhanh
ừ ừ
ý
nghĩa sự là nếu sai chứ gì
em
gà bởi vì nếu sai sẽ điều hướng hóa
thông báo đúng ạ Nếu mà điều hướng thì
mình không phải đẩy lên trên này nhá như
tội từng nói mấy ông muốn điều hướng
mình phải đun đẩy lên trên trước khi nó
có một tí hiển thị HTML ra thì nó sẽ
không điều hướng được
anh còn không ở mấy ông chị thông báo
đấy cũng được
ừ ừ
Ừ nếu em nói chung là trong trường hợp
có đúng đi đúng không ạ đúng thì mình sẽ
lấy à
con gà đúng thì mình không làm gì cả
đúng để cho người dùng cứ nhập mật khẩu
mới đã rồi mình mới đổi đúng không ạ như
là nói chung là cái thực ra là khi bấm
vào đây là gần như nhiều tra là nó xóa
sự cái to Kem này khỏi kể này rồi Chưa
cần biết ông đổ mật khẩu mới gồm nhá Ông
bấm vào đường link nhà nó xóa sư vậy
đường link này sẽ đến vô hiệu hóa rồi
anh
ở đây là sự nếu đúng thì thực là nếu sai
Anh cứ giả chuyển hướng Nếu đúng thì giữ
nguyên gì cả Cứ kệ không không không
không cần này nữa
a Summer ID
em dạo này thế cái kiểm tra vẫn đăng
kiểm tra để điều hướng thôi thấy mình
vẫn bị tống lên đây thật đã đợi minh
tính Còn nếu không thì trang này không
cần phải làm gì mà chị lại nhận mật khẩu
mới mà
ở nhà nó khác một này à
Ừ thì mình sẽ hết đồ đến một cái trang
nào đó
lâu cái chân đến trang Index chấm VP lại
kèm theo lỗi gì gì đó
em có bị sao không ạ nhưng bây giờ sự
mình nhập sai rồi
ừ ừ
ở đại ca miễn phí
anh lại không thể vào đây Em đang mua
cho mà à
em không ở đây luôn
em bận tí nhá
Mai kêu i5 pro II
Ừ anh ở đâu ạ
à à
Ừ anh âm nhạc
hiện nay một nó không vào hơi buồn cười
à à
ý là đấy sáng tại cầu SQL
for password kẻ Chắc chắn là nó trả về
dữ liệu đâu có bạn ghi rồi nhé
à à
a
pin pro
đài đây
nó không mà
anh khóc một thì đai trà xanh cái đúng
rồi nghỉ à
xe hơi lạ có cho bằng 1 đi à bằng mà
không đi
Hay lại quà bụi rồi không sao ạ
à à
anh tệ đoạn này sẽ điều hướng Còn không
thì sẽ truy cập bình thường là sự như
thế này
cho
búp bê là đai được một đậu xanh à
có cốt người nghèo
à à
ở surrey password
anh không kết cùng gì à
Ê AK nhằm xóa So sánh vai
Ừ ok ok here
ở đoạn này sẽ có cái phom để mà điều mà
khẩu mới bình thường thôi ông ạ
Nếu mà trong trong cái for này sẽ kèm
cái tô Ken ẩn nữa
Em
có Zalo nó một cái chắc là thế cho ô
đỏ Cannes
và đây sẽ là nhập mật khẩu mới không ạ
sẽ có in bút password
nên mà password và còn nhiều pô tụi nhớ
mà thời ra mình kiểu gì mình sẽ ghi đè
lên mật khẩu cũ
đổi mật khẩu
U2 sẽ ạ Ở trên là phốt
trên new password
bên này biết hết là tốt này
Em hãy đưa ra sự nhập mật khẩu mới lạ
123 ạ đánh đổi mật khẩu thì mình sẽ lại
có cái file này
bóng đá ký kết mày lên nha
à à
những bài thơ ca mình vẫn mình lấy đầu
tiên mình sẽ cầm lấy hai cái về nó
Ừ cái là Token cũng phải la password này
à
à à
chị đã Token lần này mình lại kiểm tra
một lần nữa nhé Đừng có chủ qua mình vẫn
đã kiểm tra lần nữa nhưng lần này mình
sẽ lấy á Em có số 10 đi
anh như thế Ở đây mình có thể là cao xạ
được không Thế sao được bởi vì dùng 5
dâu con lần này mình sẽ lấy là Hôm nay
có đi dạo này
ở xã Đương đại đi
ở đây Token này
Ừ nếu mà không thì lại điều hướng quay
trở lại cũng được này còn nếu mà
a customer đi trong trường hợp đi
m2 đi này à
Ừ anh ấy mà đúng thì sao mình sẽ là
mai Kelly fake ID này tại list này
anh
lại có sợ mày đi à nhớ phải axit ở đây
nó kết thúc cốt tại đây nhá ạ
Ừ nếu sang trường hợp nếu đúng thì đầu
tiên thì mình sẽ lấy được cơ sở 10 đi
ngày gọi mình à
em đổi đổi mật khẩu thôi ông ạ update
customer
set password bằng mật khẩu mới đúng
không ạ
que hay đi bằng 10 đi Anh
đang chạy như này
thế nhưng với điều kiện và và sau đó nữa
thì mình vẫn phải xóa cái xóa khỏi cái
bàn này đi nữa nên là mình lại phải xóa
theo quốc lộ 10 đi luôn cũng được họ nếu
thocan được
Ừ mẹ copy con này sống tiếp nha
Delete for này
sẽ cho Token một xóa ngay cấp số 10 anh
đi được nhé
bởi vì có số 10 đi của mình vừa là Duy
nhấ à Còn Token thì có thực ra vẫn có
thể trùng thế Mình không to Ken ở trong
trường này không trùng không được phép
dùng đúng ơi Ok này không được cái chung
Bởi vì nếu tao khen chung với thằng nhảy
sang nhầm sang được ạ người khác nếu tao
cái này phải Yoona cũng lại duy nhất các
bạn một xóm một trong hai cũng được
à à
xe
tải đưa cầu thủ chạy lại này
anh không báo lỗi gì cả Bây giờ đầu tiên
thì bạn này sẽ bị xóa đi rồi này cũng có
Summer mình sẽ bị đổ mật khẩu thì 123 đó
sẽ sau A
thì các bạn thấy được Cốc đoạn này nó
hơi bị giường dàn thì hơi tạm nhiều file
nhưng được cái cơ chế mình hiểu thì các
bạn cũng hiểu được tương đối rồi ông ạ
Đó mới chỉ ở Mình sẽ lưu lại ra một bảng
mới này để mà biết được là cụ thể ai là
người ẩn quên mật khẩu không ạ Gửi mail
cho người ấy một cách một đoạn Mã ngẫu
nhiên để khi người lại bấm vào đường
link đấy thì có thể đổi được mật khẩu
cho riêng mình như mọi người khác có thể
đổi không ạ sau đấy cập nhật thôi và xóa
khỏi các bạn này không ạ Con thường là
nếu mà Linh này nó sẽ tự động cái bảng
này cũng thường hay được một con boss 1
con boss như tội nó là trên mệt cái bên
thuê host sinh nó lúc nào nó cũng sẽ có
một cái khái niệm gọi lạc log off
khi nhận nhập a close job cái gà một cái
con ở thể chạy được cứ sau bao lâu nó
thể chạy đạt được một lần các bạn thường
ai cài thêm con con con trót này rồi
chạy một cái file pp để mà xóa liên tục
tầm 5 phút một lần kiểm tra xem lại
trong bạn này có dữ liệu gì đó quá 24 24
giờ không thì bạn xóa nó đi
xe tải
hosting nó thường hay có cơ chế này để
mà nó sẽ tự động chạy hộ các bạn một đấy
Ê hồi trước thì tôi cũng
Ừ tôi không làm một này hồi trước tôi
chỉ Ralph và cứ sau một ngày tôi gửi các
bạn Linh mạnh cái
Okay bố mẹ hai tiếng thôi cho mình tạm
kết thúc ở đây không ạ cốt này thì cái
khó đã từng có bạn hỏi sẽ cho tôi sẽ đẩy
lên nhít của tôi
a a list này không cũng khai đâu ở chung
nhà ông ông nào mà muốn muốn gì đó tôi
sẽ đẩy anh get của tôi để để mấy ông học
hỏi họ làm bé ông ấy xem qua cốt này
cũng được rồi
nhiều phết nhé Nhớ phết
U18 hôm nay kết hợp đấy nha Ờ
cô bạn kia hỏi Law in courts of Attack
Trả lời nhanh nút à
à à
ở
các Tại sao tôi tắt nhàng Lê Văn Long
à à
Xin chào bạn nhé à